[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right all right what's
going on realm
infinite what's going on christopher
hart what's going on aerodynamis what's
going on
in the building thank you for the call
sir much appreciated hustle and motivate
phantom cracking joe bailey what's going
on make sure my levels is good if i'm
sounding all right
talk to me right quick the legend john
mccaffrey should be entering
soon waiting on king you know his music
is coming
let me know if y'all can hear me how my
levels is
and uh let's talk let's talk y'all let's
talk
talk to me ain't nobody talking
24 y'all ain't nobody nobody typing
what's going on
that makes me feel welcome
my chat that's good okay there we go
infinite my man infinite
got me good there we go i mean everybody
that's a hustle motivate what's there we
go i'm feeling good
in the background you're hearing attic
breaking down tables and chairs i don't
know what you're doing back there
you can still hear that now i don't okay
y'all hear attic now
what's up monkey punch what's going on
what's going on
all right so we're going to just going
to chill out for a little bit uh
the legend himself ramen craft will be
joining us very soon
and um king will be arriving soon and
you know how he do with his theme song
so i'm gonna mute chill and we will be
back big mad mo
what's going on yeah it's the only
infinite sound like he's doing the
dishes right
i told you the attitude you sound like
you're doing the dishes bro
anyway hey yo good looking out y'all
appreciate it out of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
and before we even get started
welcome laurenville still well to the
realm
put the horns up man put the horns up in
the chat
lord of back compat lord of project
cloud and now future lord of facebook vr
so salute to him
it is endeavors and uh yeah and we
are live and thank you also realm
four thousand subscribers much
appreciated we just hit that milestone
salute to the realm you already know
what it is and
pretty quick after we had pretty quick
so welcome to the iron lords podcast and
the lords of gaming.net
episode number 174 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back in front of
the right round table for the
lord's day what is start it off hot you
making me laugh bill stop
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got
xbox's presence at tokyo game show the
nvidia 30 series graphics card
and super mario 3d all-stars to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce the lord who not only
represents the pinnacle of what it means
to be a games industry journalist
but with his unique multimedia skill set
also embodies a balanced yet heartfelt
voice
in our entire gaming community
introducing the executive editor
previews at ign
and the host of podcast unlocked ign
unfiltered
and the ride the lightning
fellow xbox fan fellow mets fan
and the lord of teslas and deloreans
everywhere
live from the bay area and kind enough
to make his debut
into the realm of the lords my man
lord ryan mccaffrey how you doing sarah
oh man thank you for having me i'm uh
i'm gonna go now because
i cannot it's only gonna be downhill
after that incredible introduction
there's no way i can live up to that
that was amazing
thank you it's it's like if ryan ever
leaves ig if you don't even need to put
a resume in he's like
just listen to this it's like you just
gotta do that right yeah you gotta walk
around with
you are an absolute lord in the realm of
what you're doing so it's only right we
show you the proper respect here at the
round
table first of all how you doing sir and
you're fresh off an amazing week at iget
i might add
what's been going on with you man oh
it's uh great to be here yeah it's
this is the fun time of year man i mean
it's uh normally we'd be doing
all kinds of conventions summer would be
convention season and
obviously we would have just come off of
gamescom uh we'd be looking ahead to
well i guess tgs which i mean we still
are but you know we're just not there
uh and but that you know this year this
is a console launch here
so this is this is the big one we've
been waiting especially
as an xbox fan i've been waiting seven
years
uh so when's the next one coming out so
uh here we are when we're
hoping you know a little bit of a fresh
start but yeah no it's i mean
ps5 looks great i can't wait to get that
with spider-man and then ratchet shortly
after in the launch window
and and the series x you know it's the
series x is going to go right there
where the next
space lines up well sure and then uh i
mean
and then the ps5 i mean i'm not ripping
the side i'm just saying it
are you gonna have to go if those
if those ar estimates are enough it's
actually not gonna fit in this uh
you're gonna put it up on top yeah you
gotta move the pictures out
no but you put it on top and then you
put the ac right next to it
i'm just happy to have two new consoles
that's all i just want new hardware
absolutely man you know i know you've
been busy but have you been got a chance
to play anything sorry i think
you know i've been played recently in
the game lately uh just
dip my toe in with uh with battle toads
which i had a pretty good time with
first few missions
uh not bad so uh and then what else i
mean
uh nothing else lately it's a lot of pre
i mean it's just it works stuff but in a
good way like uh but i've just been
previewing a bunch of games
all the stuff that you know embargoes
will be up over the course of the week
so
i can't just detail it all for you not
with any kind of like military secret
but
you know they don't they don't like me
talking about these things before it's
time to talk about these things
but yeah it's uh it's preview season you
know we're getting a look at everything
and
and uh it's gonna be good man it's gonna
be a good
fall yeah yeah definitely looking
forward to it console launch season
absolutely impressive lord saw if you
want to get that super chat before we
get into our intro
of course we have lord snowden with the
five dollar super chat
welcome fam how you all doing keep up
the good work iop and log net team
oh yes i appreciate it he's doing he's
doing a ton of work too man i
i i wanted to you know let him know that
i've been appreciating all the hard work
that he's been putting out absolutely i
also want to salute
i see the chat mc fixer lord fc fixers a
little bit
you did fantastic with ryan man i caught
that loved the pastor he was a blast
yeah he was great he was great man it's
a salute to him so oh while they're
coming in right now
squirrel dan we have squirly dan with
the two dollar super chat
sorry i'm a bit late but let's go ilp
much love
yellow knife canada man that's that's
the homie right there salute
and you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table
now with our updated time sensitive
because ryan is here intros
my goal is the co-host my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir i'm
doing
great
i ended up playing wasteland three till
like six in the morning
nice day and i'm surprised i have this
much energy which is probably fake so
we'll continue going on and see how that
goes nice
jonathan feed through time right quick
so i got to do it as a joke time
wow
so that's been it and of course we have
our most technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patron of
the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir i
am doing fantastic i got 10 hours of
sleep last night
you must not have children no there you
go
i got 10 in preparation of only getting
four for the next
for the foreseeable future
my saturdays those are my sleep nights
but you can get 10 hours of sleep
yeah yeah that's only on saturday
he's done he's going to be happy next
week now
yeah yeah no i know i know anything
you've been playing sir
uh yeah actually i went ahead and picked
i had a hole burning in my uh microsoft
wallet and i said let me get tony hawk's
pro skater one and two wow
wow man they really
really like that really i've been i know
how many times have you purchased
that game really i i've no uh on the way
twice
on the real i've been look man if i
could buy resident evil 4 18 times i
could buy tony hawk twice
have you enjoyed the experience so it's
been good yeah it's fantastic just to
see it running smoothly
they added uh just the lighting effects
just to see that game
updated properly is kind of fantastic
um i was never the greatest at it before
but honestly the extra the extra frames
you know
[Laughter]
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this
aka the access gamer
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
we're doing fantastic riot
hold
that is that is something else i am
impressed
there for a second i thought mario was
absent but did i see him on the way
where's mario he's at the bottom right
oh my god
so that's another inside you can
one day he's gonna have him on that
rotating thing that flashes
if you didn't see the kos that's up
right now please go check it out it's a
heartfelt
uh kos it's about my imaginary friend
who uh
passed away and uh just check it out uh
this week
what i've been playing i'm you know
captain game pass has been in his bag
okay i'm especially happy
for drake's hollow yes um i saw that
game on the floor
at pax east i had to run to it we had to
get the interview
and um i'm so happy that we got the
interview with the developer we got it
up to go to lognet right now to go check
that out yes yes please
also okay i'm gonna bust you upside your
head what
i put inside that wasteland three
oh my god you were definitely right
it's definitely on steroids and i was
just like okay
i gotta respect the game i wasn't
respecting the game
in the beginning so after the four four
first four times that i died
i said okay we're gonna have to respect
this game
we're gonna have to take it easy so
definitely something to get into
something to you know to peel back the
layers of the onion
right um also a resonator drop so
i just stopped playing it in vr because
i'm
my heart can't take it it's a bit much
it's a bit much yeah
it's real so i'm playing it on my ex
right now and also
uh the last uh last one i've dropped
where is it at um it's a spirit
of your hair spiritually yes yes yes yes
i just downloaded it and i was going to
play it this morning but i was like let
me get some proper sleep
before ryan gets on because i definitely
want to be completely coherent here
i said i'll definitely play later on
today uh but a lot of recommendations
for that game so i'm gonna definitely
check it out
salute salute lord king again catch that
kos if you the king of the statues if
you have not missed a great flash
introduction and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realness to
the realm of iop not telling you what
you want to hear but what you need
to hear great last word on friday who's
breaking dishes somebody's breaking
dishes anyway
great laughs it's not me
shout out to squirrely dan though you
want to get that real quick yeah we have
a few actually
we have dan rodriguez from season gaming
with the 5000's
prediction time ryan which will be
louder the ps5 or your tesla oh my god
this is really
what we're already about to smoke
that might be a closer race than you
think
lords thanks for keeping me company on
the ride home fantastic then we have my
brother lord kaibatsu with the 2
super chat yeah oh i can't believe he's
awake he's awake
iop with another week of bangers gotta
love it
sir absolutely and we have squirrely dan
yet again with the two dollar super chat
welcome to the realm of the lords ryan
mccaffrey much love much love thank you
much love so yeah man again so last word
was on friday shout out to ebantus we
killed it had a
young content creator they bought it my
five man really good
he's really growing out there about 70
70k subs but he's just
comprehensive weapon review just really
good that so good laughs
check that up it's on ilp and now for me
game wise it's still i'm at the very end
of goes to sushima
i'm just trying to get that finished up
the companion quests are really i'm
really enjoying those man
that uh attic all know about that crazy
lady lady masako she her storyline's
crazy you gotta watch that's a great
storyline
check that out but enough about me um we
gotta someone else is like stuck in the
back door
the lord of gaming.net editor himself
lord undead nicholas downey how are we
doing sir
i am alive and well and recovering from
my usual saturday night hangover
thank you thank you canada represent
what's going on so look i'll i'll set uh
undead up here real quick the reason why
he's here then we'll get into business
look
obviously proud of the original vision
of lords of gaming.net myself
lord dizzy obviously undead lord hyde
lord josh reading
all the editorial team obviously in 2020
we just hit our one-year-old birthday
so salute to that and it's a short time
we did some really cool things man
obviously you got source
for ign wcf tech window central
you know and now recently to be accepted
by uh open critic as a review aggregate
is super
super humbling so um but today we want
to do something special undead right we
got a little something special in the
realm
of lords of gaming.net so i'm gonna let
you take it away
and set up what we try to do yeah so
just as a little celebratory thing um
we don't obviously share uh numbers and
everything else
but year over year lords of gaming from
when it started
all the way back in 2019 we are on
track currently we last month we did
three times what we did last year in
traffic
and just this month alone six days
in we are currently on track we doubled
what we did in three
months in the past five days with the
site so really proud of all the
people that contribute content and just
overall
make a great team experience here at
lords of gaming.net
and as a salute so to speak
we want to highlight some of our writers
that do
amazing work it's an amazing team filled
with many talented people
and we just every month we're going to
be um
showcasing um a certain writer who has
done some particularly good work
or has just been a huge part of the
success
of this team so for the first time
uh we have our scribe of the month who
is a very
very good friend of mine uh mr jared
eden who has been
doing and fantastic job with our
grounding coverage oh my god and our
survival guides and everything else he's
a
fantastic writer he's done exceptional
work for us over the past a
few weeks and he's only going to get
better as time goes on so he is the
official
log net right scribe of the month the
inaugural the first one
ever the first one and it makes me so
proud because this guy is someone i've
worked with for
two and a half years across a handful of
sites
and to watch him grow and continue to
prosper has been
a thing of beauty and i'm absolutely
proud
um to work hand in hand with him on
previews reviews and everything we've
got cooking up for the month of
september
that's it for me i appreciate you lord
and thank you for coming through again
scribe of the month something we'll be
doing every month at the other month to
salute our riders again
we really appreciative jared has been
excellent if you are a fan of grounded
he is the lord of grounded he will give
you the best walkthroughs you will ever
see
and tell you how to get level 2 level 3
items the man is fantastic also his
mortal shell
review was uh picked up by the developer
he's really been fantastic man so salute
again
jared and you already know what the
words you could go up to that uh iop
uh team shop get you some nice loads of
gaming swag to rewatch yourself sir
that's your
your reward for the month so again we'll
be doing this monthly we'll have some
quarterly awards and also an end of the
year award again salute to the whole
team
super proud of you guys and thank you
very much undead you are the man thank
you sir
have a great day guys all right man all
right thank you let's solve if you want
to get the super chances
oh yes yeah we gotta catch up we have
the black spartan with the one pound uh
super chat uh just say something brother
say something please
then we have stitch with the five dollar
super chat switch to the bushes
my tesla runs games better than that
720p handheld oh my god
oh my god wow oh my lord
ryan's laughing
look i'm pretty sure that the tesla
probably does run stuff better
anyway smitty smith with the five dollar
super chat
shout out to lognet iop the last word
lord addicts reviews and kos salute
the book of acts oh we got it with you
smith
book of acts emoji for you continue then
we have the wandering dutch with the two
pound super chat good afternoon
all hope you're all good on the other
side of the pond wanderer duck
we will be working together soon sir
what else you got then we have jd gamer
with the
two dollar super chat good afternoon
good afternoon good afternoon ilp
good afternoon brother no no i see jared
in there salute congratulations on your
award sir
what else we got then we have kids move
with the following oh that's the best
spot
the best bot congrats iop lords of
gaming welcome to the realm ryan
hashtag get kids move over podcast oh my
god
you can't be shooting yo
kids be professional sir
bro you're popular they love you man
they love it we have mostly martinez
with the five dollar super chat hey ryan
happy to see you grace the realm
how's that uh robotech computer treating
you aerobie tech computing
tech yeah justin taking care of me
beautiful everyone have a blessed day
hashtag pc master race
until the series x shout out to the 3800
and then we got one more
then we have gerald mack with the five
dollar super chat congratulations iop
to all your accomplishments and
accolades shout out to the bay area ryan
mccaffrey get it
in bay area representing no doubt so
salute to the chat wow
l paul get him real quick follow super
chat must support quality
congrats iop much success in the future
wow thank you
smitty smith final two chat lord king
that flash was the
now we got all the announcements finally
out the way you know saying what the
lords have been playing i want to start
our focus with lord ryan
his video game system history his
journey into game journalism
with the official xbox games magazine
and of course what led him to become the
executive editor of previews
for ign so lord ryan let's start from
the very beginning
well some of the first video game
systems you had what got you into gaming
i'll tell you it was uh i don't know
what friend what whose house
it was at but it was when i saw super
mario brothers so i'm turning 40 in two
weeks so that's i'm the right age for
the original nintendo
and so at some point yes sir at some
point
i saw super mario brothers and just
started playing as like this is amazing
like this is this is great video games
are fantastic
yeah i'd never i don't i don't remember
ever playing an atari or anything
anywhere else i certainly didn't have
have any video game systems but yeah
super mario bros was my
my catalyst my entry point into video
games
and then from there i'll tell you it was
it was i used my first communion money
catholic kids know what's up
yeah to buy uh my own nintendo wow and
well i would have been
i guess i mean i didn't get it right in
85 86 it was uh
it was more like 80s 87 88 somewhere
right around there and
and yeah just started off it started off
with it and my friends all
were into video games too i mean you
know it was
that was the nintendo was it for
everybody it was all of us
you know what's kind of crazy ryan like
yeah everyone at the beginning with
those first couple consoles like they
remember getting it a couple years into
the
into the uh to the the life of the
system not thinking like that now i'm
like
i couldn't go like three days at night
for three years back then that's how
addiction works
that's wrong without it you need that
new
fix you've got something better okay get
it right and right in these veins let's
go
yeah baby you know serious xps five oh
straight into my veins hook it up
real quick real quick we have a special
super chat for you
shout out to the legendary the great
wall himself bill stillwell tell us in
the chat
ryan is easily the second best guest
ever on iop
who am i kidding he's number one when i
got to jersey
super penny yeah he's one of the few
right it's got that legendary ilp jersey
right there so it's
absolutely great i love bill bill's a
bill's a dear friend man he's uh he's a
great person
thank you but continue your journey i
just had to ask you which nes was it the
the light gun one was it the rob one was
it oh yeah it would have been
it was the super mario brothers duck
hunt combo cart yeah
yeah that was uh which i feel like that
was
probably most people had that right
because that was i don't know
i guess they weren't offering that in
the beginning before i you know knew
about it but i feel like that was
at least everybody that i knew that was
that was the one you got
absolutely was the the mario brothers
duck hunt combo cartridge
and then uh but but it's like i don't
know about
about any of you guys but it was duck
hunt was like
just the other game yes
crackdown it was like
it was like it's same thing like with
the master system it was hang on
and then you had safari hunting right
and then yeah at that point would you
say
ryan i felt it was more of a tool to
showcase the light gun more than
anything
as opposed to like uh what do you think
yeah i never of course you don't think
about it that way as a kid but
but yeah i guess i don't know like i
don't know maybe i guess if i'm
i never really thought about it so
that's a good question i guess thinking
about it now
i would i would imagine they were
nintendo was thinking about it like oh
this will this is this will be like
translating the arcade
experience yeah into the home because of
course arcade gaming was
the only way to really the game until i
mean yes there was the atari and all
that but but that was
arcades were the primary vehicle for
video games so
yeah you put in a light gun game in
there and it and that's makes it seem
like oh okay yeah that's like the arcade
experience at home so
it was it was the best one for me
because i got the whole big package i
got you know
robin robot yeah for no reason
yeah he only worked like one time
and when he did it i was like okay rob
you're done
showing my friends like showtime rob
yeah all right
is you guys might as well be speaking
another language
this is the lord addicts one of our
younger lords this is before his time
frame so we
were talking talk know your history
thank you
so from there right it was so it was nes
now did you stay in the console space
did you oh yeah for a while so
um we were my family was as middle class
as it got
and i only say that is to preface what
i'm about to say with where i went next
with games so it was
i uh i ended up owning a lot of the
systems but
only ever one at a time i never had
because i always had to trade in one to
get the next one
yes but you know as that addiction got
got deeper
my friend it's funny my best friend
robert and i we
we bucked the trend we decided you know
what i don't know we've been reading egm
we decided we decided to go with the
turbo graphics 16.
you know what first of all first king is
loving that let me say you
all i'm sorry bill
i'm sorry dude wait hold on you can't
sleep bill got we got 3d oh love with
bill come on yeah i know yeah we do
we do bottom turbo graphics the only
person
with a turbo graphics 16. yeah and he
just said he went from a nintendo
to a turbo graphics 16 oh he if you show
it
all right don't do it you're gonna be a
legend out here
it's fantastic they did a great job on
this yes
it's okay bill i still love you i have
no clue what they're talking about okay
what if you don't even have 3d outside
right okay to hell what they gonna say
right
tell them what it was like when you put
on the key courage
dude that game was awesome especially
when you like left you transformed into
the suit like you got the
voltron that game was cool yeah that was
that was a good game that was an
underrated packing right there keith
courage in the alphas
in the alpha zones what that was good
stuff legendary actions
legendary there were a lot of great i
mean yeah of course was
was uh was there mario these sound like
rated c
movies every 1980s early 1990s video
game title sounds
sounds like that that's it's not just
turbo graphics
every nintendo game's like that too but
yeah i'll tell you so and then um
and my buddy robert his you know his
family were a little more well to do so
robert at one point got
for his birthday like i guess the next
year maybe it would have been
uh after we got our each got the turbo
graphics 16. he got the cd-rom
attachment which at the time
as i recall it i may pardon me if i'm
just this old and foggy memory i
think it was 300 bucks it was like 19
you know which in 2020 money that's
probably like a four or five hundred
dollars
it was no joke to get that thing but but
there had never been a cd-rom ad on
for uh for a game console before and
just
you gotta i mean you have to have lived
it to understand
because i don't know anything about you
know whatever you guys talking about so
you're talking about like
you bought something that's like three
to four hundred dollars just to add on
to yes it was an attachment
my best friend did i did not have that
it was just like
it was like the equivalent of like
buying the the v the ps4 vr
today like it was like even yeah
more expensive than that i would say it
was like it was like buying a
series x to add on good
analogy but ryan definitely it was
absolutely a must-have item for the
turbo graphics
there were so many good cd games yeah
when you went over this house what was
the first game
in my head i i know what the game is but
say it
ease exactly right oh wow
east book one and two was that
yeah that game okay so i'm glad you
brought this up
that game had which again blows you away
at the time
uh it had a fully voice-over narrated
introduction
which you've never seen before it was
just like
ease yeah
and so yeah and also just a great
role-playing game a great action rpg i
i've actually
personally just i've never been a big
jrpg guy
but of course east developed in japan
but it's it's kind of an action rpg i
mean
you literally run run into guys at
an angle to attack them yeah it's weird
like if you run into them head-on you're
probably going to get hurt you got to
kind of like
graze by them as as if you're striking
them with your sword but
oh it's shattered east was great one of
the greatest
game soundtracks of all time that
developer was known for their tremendous
soundtrack work but yeah i mean there
were so many
anyway so i i didn't have so i had to
live vicariously through my best friend
robert at his house yeah that's
what we stayed up i remember when when
he got it we stayed up
all night playing east book one and two
that game was
was incredible but uh but then
eventually
we eventually i moved on to i traded
that in
and got i can't remember i think genesis
was next
went to genesis of course killer sports
games
the best the ea sports games were better
on the genesis
than they were on the super nes versus
celtics oh
yeah absolutely one of the things that i
envy
about when you guys grew up is like
right now in the generation our group's
like neither nintendo
playstation or xbox at least you guys
got like we got the genesis here and
then we got some other system i ain't
never heard of because it was a
different time
like it was it was it was less fanboy i
mean there were some moments obviously
the genesis does and all that stuff but
the reality is it was kind of like what
ryan said where it's like if you didn't
have it your friend had it so you went
over your friend's house
to go check out the other experience
king was that for us like it's just
exactly
yeah it was just all that stuff right
now yeah it's it's like
music to my ears because every time i
hear somebody tell a history
it's either super nintendo or genesis
yeah you're right super nintendo or
genesis
you know i was that neo geo turbo
graphics out of the box dude
but the turbo graphics when i put on
that cd
it was mind-blowing for me like loads of
thunder gates of thunder
that stuff like that that stuff it was
just
yeah you know
let me ask you right have you not seen
what's behind him
hey it's you know i don't know how you
grow up versus how you are now
i mean oh yeah yeah i
i did the 250 cartridge thing that's him
i
there was a local video game store so
i'm from new jersey but i
uh we moved out to arizona the whole
family moved out when i was in grade
school so i mostly grew up in arizona
and there was this
there was this independent video game uh
store there they had a couple locations
in town but it was called gamers
and the reason i bring this store up is
because well that's also that's where i
traded it that's where i would trade in
my games and system to get the next one
but right
because they dealt in used games and
trade-ins
but the cool thing about gamers the ways
that i loved going there
is they had in the sort of near the
front window of the store
they had a station set up with each
system that was
that was out right and you could you
could rent time and just
play game like you could rent basically
games you could play for 10 minutes
on a neo geo or a turbo graphics with a
cd or a super
nes or you know was it i don't know
however much
much it was for 10-15 minutes or you
could do an hour or whatever
and that's the only place i could i ever
saw or beheld or even played a neo-geo
and i just remember the
the giant card yeah it's huge
was like literally arcade quality yeah
it was
it was incredible yeah it was stunning
it could literally kick right go from
the your system with the memory card to
home and back and
for if i can remember right yeah when we
was down when we went to elizabeth
street we would take our memory card
wherever we was at in the game
and we would put it inside the the the
the machine the cabinet
and we would leave off where we left off
at the house that's awesome so
you know that was that that was i mean i
worked because i
had a hard time pretty much or you know
to to to get this stuff
um you know and i worked in video game
stores
so i was you know uh like whatever work
i was doing
let's say i work i'll tell her i don't
pay me the money yeah you'll be like pay
me in systems yes
i remember that you pay me man that's
awesome i'm gonna be here anyway i love
this stuff
so uh just pay me in cartridges
we have lord braf with the 20 super cat
super cat super chat
are you sure you're okay thank you
salute lord it's awesome to see ryan on
iop woo
no doubt then we have lord six slayer
with the five dollar super chat
i used my first communion money to get
an nes just like ryan
oh that's absolutely perfect then we
have emmanuel a1 with the five dollar
super chat salute to iop and ryan for
using his platform to help show the
diversity in xbox
and content creators let's get kids move
on unlocked
and stuff then we have a pixel bit g
with the five dollar super chat
i went from commodore to turbo graphics
to 3do respect
shout out to the gates of thunder and
lord of thunder yes
also a great sound stereo sound which
there's a soundtrack
awesome heavy metal hell yeah what else
we got
and we have neil mental with the ten
dollar super chat yo shout out to my
guys on a great show thank you brother
thank you brother
then we have [ __ ] with the five dollar
super chat someone tell mrs king that he
found the new love with ryan
that turbo graphics level
don't uh please say something brother
please please yeah
croatia i believe so he's keeping
trouble for all the creation writes for
us continue
and we have suicide king with the fifty
dollars oh wow wow thank you brother
thank you brother well they had to catch
the og ryan mccaffrey live in the realm
unlock was the first podcast i ever
listened to and i've been a huge fan
ever since
check out ign unfiltered and we will
talk about that
oh yeah a really special long-form
interview show so cool to see ryan on
iop
absolutely
291 people watching live so hit that
like button now
thank you brother oh and let me know
what day i'm gonna be on your show will
yeah yeah so we got uh oh hold on that's
in there
yeah we have a few okay we have our
scribe of the month jared we do we have
our scribe of the month jared eden with
the five uh
dollar super chat from uh canada thank
you for the wonderful words earlier
means a ton my pleasure putting in that
work shout out to lord ryan for being an
inspiration
well absolutely you keep it up keep it
up brother you doing fantastic
absolutely then we have the cycle gamer
with the five dollar super chat
ryan what are you expecting from battery
day what
what do you have to charge the car i'm
assuming oh yeah i know it's yeah it's
it's tesla stuff yeah don't worry about
it no it's uh
hopefully i want to see i'll
i'll throw some weird other weird words
at you guys who aren't sure
the plaid model s and you guys are like
what aren't you
talking about cyclists yeah cycles
appreciate it
because he said also do you think tesla
would extend the type of partnership
they have with target
to a company like walmart okay i hope so
yeah the more the merrier
they need more charging stations all
over yeah you want to get uh clowns
you wanted to go yeah i missed he said i
missed the video game isla toys r us uh
old school
yes i brought super mario brothers 2. i
had this vivid memory
of going and just it was the they had it
at the very beginning of the aisle
and you go you take the paper ticket out
of the plastic sleeve and then you take
it to the locked security counter and
then they'd hand you your game
bro man those were those memories what's
funny is like
i had like the back end memories for
toys r us like it wasn't for like gaming
stuff because they used to play yu-gi-oh
and they used to always have tournaments
with toys r us so like but i never
bought games really there i just took
what i won from there and bought stuff
yes but that's a classic man you want to
go continue yourself
yeah yeah knock these out
you know listen ryan is
you have jd gamer with the five dollar
super chat ryan we know you went from
nintendo to turbo graphic 16 but where
did you go from there
please tell me you took some time to
enjoy the sega saturn
is that the super chat
glad to see ryan on the show love
everything you guys do salute gaming
forte
that not hitting that like until addict
puts his uniform out
today in front of company
but then we have lord brat once again
with the five dollar super chat
ryan love the aux i'm demo disc the
ninja gaiden demo disc was fine
all right so all right let's go caught
up we got to move on and thank you
guys super appreciative so look we got
that you moved on
you went and then you turn a ball you
kept on now did you have a touch pc or
that was kind of it genesis yeah let's
get started i'm sorry i'll fast forward
because it's uh
otherwise we'll be here all day yeah and
yeah at some point
you know whether or not i got whether it
was i got tired of the genesis or what
again
traded that and all the games traded it
all in and saved up some allowance money
or whatever it was
and and then i did cross over and do the
super nintendo
so uh which again i mean at some point
i'd played it and you know different
friend had it so i played super mario
world and pilot wings and all that stuff
but uh in fact i remember renting when
when the super nintendo first came out
did like a did like an all-nighter like
a sleepover party at a
mo you know a bunch of us at a friend's
house we rented the console
from blockbuster when you could rent
systems
yes yeah uh with with the super mario
world and pilotwings and yes
good memories there but eventually i did
move on to the super nintendo
nice that was that mode seven glorious
for pollution exactly yeah it was good
stuff man
and then uh and then yeah and then from
there
i think that then at that point i would
have i
i got the turbo duo which uh
king knows what's up yeah so then then i
finally had my own
that was when they basically did the
turbo graphics with the cd-rom but there
was a super scene there was like a 3.0
update version and just all into one
sleek unit and then i had that
uh so i was back in the turbo graphics
realm for a while
uh before making one final console stop
at least for
a long time which was uh which was the
atari jaguar
oh
three campaigns you could play as the
alien play as
the marines play as the predator uh that
game was creepy as hell it had
no soundtrack it was just violent
it was that sound and yeah it was just
that was
i mean i don't know in hindsight how i
played it on that weird controller
this keypad at the bottom and i don't
know how the heck i played it but you
know that was
that was before i ever knew mouse and
keyboard or twin thumb sticks so
um yeah that was short-lived and then
from there
just to end this to end the story is uh
uh again that was you got to remember
this era so now we're at about 1993
192 years after i was born
[Laughter]
and in the early 90s not every household
had a computer they were
still three thousand plus dollar
things it was not everybody had one yet
this is right when people were just
starting to get computers in their homes
played doom at a friend's house
i mean that's a whole other show in
itself of like what are your
what are your all-time like changed your
life
yeah yeah oh doom is one of them i mean
super mario brothers for me
doom uh grand theft auto 3 is one of
those for me
halo 2 is one of those for me because of
the online stuff
but but yeah doom just like rocked my
world completely and then it was
i gotta get a computer so eventually
sweet talk my parents
oh i need it for school
let me ask you a question when you when
you got your pc was it a 3d fx voodoo
card
no it was before that my friend it was
before
this was yeah no there was it was it was
a packard bell
as it came to be known packaged hell
brand ever a terrible machine
but yeah it was a packard bell 486
and i think i i can't remember it might
have been
wow maybe a 50 megahertz maybe
i can't it was it was a while ago it's
too long ago to remember but
um yeah that was before that was before
dedicated graphics
you had the integrated things oh yeah
yeah but anyway uh yeah doom changed my
world and then i
i became i left consoles behind for a
long long time
uh and was just pc gaming exclusively
and just so many of my all-time fondest
gaming memories are on pc between
i mean doom and then heretic and hexen
and
dark forces and jedi knight and diablo
one and then diablo two more
like diablo two is a top five all-timer
for me
uh so many great men and of course all
the all the lucas arts point-and-click
adventure games
yes just such again my friend robert and
i my buddy robert and i we would we
would just
stay up all night and go through i
remember when we got full throttle
in the horizontal box from babbages and
it was
60 bucks that was like when remember
that was back when
babbages would get games before the big
box
retailers because video games weren't
this ubiquitous
like companies didn't understand how
how lucrative and popular video games
were and so you had these dedicated
video game shops and malls
like a babbages like a software etc that
would get the games
first before the toys r us and the
and the you know the the kmarts and the
what-have-yous would get them
so if you wanted that game first you'd
go to babbages
and it was more money it was 60 bucks
for uh for some of those new releases
like yeah i mean so many great teams
yeah they were very ryan's right like
very enthusiast kind of spots at that
time they didn't realize like
how you like you said how lucrative
things were man this is tremendous
and i remember those point clicking i
think for me it was like my one was like
monkey monkey's island yeah yeah i got
your feet yeah
i just love that game speaking to that
like brad with the two dollars super
chat ryan remember
king's quest i mean i do but i
i actually i don't know the the sierra
adventure games never did it for me i
was a lucas arts guy i just liked the
i don't know it was something but but i
certainly king's quest police quest yeah
it's uh i remember those sierra games
for sure
leisure suit larry
we have a neo mentor with the 5 super
chat i'm sorry but ryan is out here
stealing my life's experiences right now
then we have uh echelon seven the
darkness with the five dollar
chat piece to the lords if xbox acquires
a graphical showcase for series x
your choice wukong or bright memory
yeah we'll get they already got bright
memories yeah
not a wukong so he says uh hi ryan and
daisy and rest in peace to maggie
oh salute thank you and then we have the
wandering dutch with the two pounds
super chat
little big adventure okay remember i
don't
know
pixel bit g with the two dollar super
chat pirates point look at this
man's conversation but anyway we got to
move on because we're going history all
day at
tremendous gaming history by the
legendary ryan mccaffrey so what asks is
the journalism side you know and and
just getting your feet wet
you know what inspired you specifically
to the industry was just your love for
the passion for consoles
and then obviously the transition to oxm
you know and
getting started this how did that all
come about i feel
so i writing and english were always my
strongest subjects in school
and i obviously loved video games and i
read egm religiously
and then once they came around and i was
super into pc gaming i read pc gamer
from almost almost
issue one from religiously from the
beginning and
and somewhere around i guess it would
have been i don't think it was before it
was probably high school not
not middle school it would have been
high school i think where i just thought
you know what
i want to do this i want one of the
names in this magazine and this this is
what i want to do
and so i i consider myself very
fortunate to have
to have known early exactly what i
wanted to do because
you know it's a lot of friends a lot of
people they're still figuring themselves
out in
in high school and certainly in college
and even beyond like and there's nothing
wrong with that you know
you're figuring out what you want to do
who you want to be i just
i i feel fortunate that i was able to
focus because i i
had that dream in mind like i knew what
i wanted to do
right and so uh i
went to to arizona state which you know
big party school reputation but they had
they had a great journalism program the
walter cronkite school of journalism so
wow i went there just again with this
laser focus in mind and i knew
like all right i gotta just i gotta
dominate this as much as i can
and when i get out of here i i'll have a
that'll give me my best chance of doing
of fulfilling this dream and and
you know becoming uh somebody who writes
about games for a living
so you know i i just i tr i treated
college
which i have a few little regrets over i
i just took it
it was a job to me like i would raise a
focus
i didn't go to a single football game
like they're i wish i had taken more
advantage in hindsight this is i mean
not that not to like turn this into an
armchair therapy session
i wish i'd taken a little bit more
advantage of the college experience
because really
once that's over it's you don't really
get that back
those are your time that's your time but
at the same point i
can't say i have any i can't say that i
am not mad about it because i i
accomplished my goal i i
made you who you are i've been
transforming it got me where i wanted to
go and
uh when i graduated i started as soon as
i graduated i sent out a cover letter
and a resume to every game magazine
and website that i could think of just
like just going to blast it out there
and i would say and and i got had a
couple little nibbles here and there but
one day
official xbox magazine writes back and
you know what
we actually we've we've got an opening
uh why don't you you know send some
some writing samples so i i went to the
newsstand i went to the grocery store
and i bought official xbox magazine for
the first for the first time
you're like look at you guys i need to
do research these guys
that's the story that's funny now that i
didn't fit for a long time
but uh yeah so i i sent him some writing
samples uh in the style of like
different
in the the style of the different
sections of the magazine and
uh i must have impressed upon them
enough because they finally wrote back
at one point and said well
all right we'd like to fly you out for
an interview wow and
uh then i i guess i impressed them
enough and
they took a chance on me and hired this
22 year old kid fresh out of college
i guess the real quick the other funny
part of the story that i just skipped
over is
it was as soon as they said we're gonna
fly you out for an interview
that's when i went to the store and
bought an x-box
time to do your research ryan don't want
to walk into their headquarters there's
an xbox controller he's like what's this
oh my god hold on real quick with this
bill
let's get bill still with the five
dollar super chat leisure suit larry was
the last game i played as a boy
after that yeah
they had bill will remember this there
was a you had to answer
questions really in order to access
leisure suit larry because it was an
adult content
history questions that only someone 18
or older
that was a parental multiple choice
gating that was back yeah
remember there's no there's really no
internet at this point google like who
was president in 1968 like
exist so but yeah that was the actual
like
parental content protection mode you had
to
contribute questions to get
a kid would not know the answers to
these questions
but once you click it because trust me
that that game like like bill said
you're not a boy after this game you
transformed a lot of a lot of inspiring
youth
when you guys talk about like these old
call and sitting these old guys part of
me feels like man
i missed out but then you guys then you
guys start talking about like the actual
games i'm like
okay i'm okay
i appreciate the time i grew up in oh
yeah so yeah like i said oxf stuff like
that i just want to ask you a question
in reference to oxm um
i thought one of the coolest things
about the mac was obviously those
you know like vintage demo discs right
so like
who was the th who was behind the
thought process of including that
in the magazine like i thought that was
really cool well that was
so that was before my time when when so
oxm was published my employer was
future future publishing and they had
at the time they they published pc
gamers so this magazine that i dreamed
of getting into was right down the hall
i was also a big fan king might know
about this pc accelerator you might
remember that
yes content the pc excel
is so funny they did a feature one time
where they played flight simulator games
drunk
like they did stuff like that they
they're most legendary things sorry i
know i'm going off on them
no no no no do it please and i learned i
became an employee and
because my boss mike salmon our
editor-in-chief
was actually the editor-in-chief of pc
accelerator oh okay and then he moved
over to oxm after pc accelerator folded
but
uh they they did a preview of
i believe it would have been i guess
tomb raider three
in pc accelerator and again the whole
they're trying to they're
an edgy funny buddy
the preview yes
imagine this the preview in the magazine
yes
was tomb raider two but they just
like crossed out the two and put a three
totally leaned into the joke of like
this is the same thing
and apparently i learned later that uh
idos got really pissed off
i don't know if they i don't remember if
they said if they pulled advertising or
not but yeah
it's crazy to think that stuff like that
still goes to this day it's the same
game like
nothing's changed we're looking for new
experiences
and let me tell you something
obviously not with this madden stuff
anyway um
but but what we were looking for like i
said was new experiences
new horizons and stuff like that so if
you didn't push the boundaries
a lot of these editors will hold your
feet to the fire and they
really didn't care at that point in time
so you would be
able to get these magazines because
trust me these magazines stake they
claim
on being reputable when we picked up an
egm
or uh we picked up a game informer
or these magazines and we read them
we believed exactly what they were
saying and we purchased
on this because we didn't have a try uh
stuff out like you know game pass and
stuff yeah i mean
you know yeah so you guys were
definitely our first line of defense
to finish answering the question about
the demo real quick
so yeah i uh oxm started i i started uh
at in issue 12 i think it was so i came
to year in so oxidized started but to
just answer the question about the demo
disk
yeah that was so future sorry that's how
i got off track
you know future was doing pc gamer and
pc gamer had a demo disc a cd-rom
disc with with pc game demos on it every
month
right and so it was they knew that was a
concept that worked
like that was hugely pc gamer was a
huge success got it for many many many i
mean it's still successful now it's one
of the only things still standing at
future right it pains me to say that
that that's a company that's a publisher
that's uh you know fallen
far but uh so when they they
signed this deal with microsoft knowing
that the top this xbox console was
coming
right and they said we want to be the
official
because official playstation magazine
existed but it was published by a
different company
i guess it would have been it would have
been ziff at the time
and uh which ironically that's who i
work for now is it
anyway so yeah they they successfully
pitch microsoft we want to do your
official magazine
and and by the way just to clarify
people ask me this all the time
if i did not work for microsoft
microsoft had
no say over our content nice
the only thing so we paid future paid
microsoft not the other way around
people clarify
paid microsoft to use the official xbox
logo
and call it the official xbox one so
that was the nature of the relationship
of what official meant but
it's important anyway uh so
they started them and they and they
pitched they said you know we we do pc
gamer and with that disc and
so we we'd like to work with you to do a
playable demo disc for xbox with every
issue
right and microsoft agreed to it and uh
and so
that was part of the core identity of
official xbox magazine from the jump and
and we had a
one of our editors uh still a good
friend of mine to this day
dave reese shout out to dave he was the
guy that
like his whole job like he did stuff for
the magazine like the occasional review
and stuff but his
primary job was putting together that
demo disc
every month and reaching out to
developers and
trying to get their demos on and like
his his day revolved around that disc
and he did a tremendous job
we had so many killer discs over the
years i mean oxm was the first place
that the public could play ninja gaiden
which was referenced by
somebody earlier uh splinter cell chaos
theory i remember we had the lighthouse
mission mission one
that was the first place you could play
chaos theory in fact the original
splinter cell that was alex number
the first place that the public could
play that because again there was no
marketplace
yep there was a different marketplace
you couldn't download the demo like they
could be
exactly right yeah that that's
that's where the disk came from and
that's sort of what it was uh
it was the famous penny arcade well
famous to us that always
that always stung i mean i've i've i've
met jerry and mike and i've talked to
them and they're they're nice guys i
have no beef with them
it was there was a um a penny arcade
one many many many years ago that that
definitely hurt which was
the joke was uh they like
got oxm and they were super excited they
were like
yeah super excited and then you see the
third panel it's
they're throwing the magazine in the
track oh we had magazine wars
no i saw i saw that one and it you know
because
you know a lot of people would say they
were only getting it for the demo disc
and you know that's not true actually
because the articles inside was
definitely great stuff you know so
that's not true i remember that we had a
we i'll tell you we had a great team i
i am so grateful to have gotten to spend
my 20s at oxm my which was also the
first 10 years of my career
like that team mike and frank and
fran and tom and julianne
and and uh and just everybody on the
team like
dave we had such a great crew
it was i mean you just that doesn't
exist anymore
and really because everything like the
world has changed and the world's moved
on and social medias
changed everything and i just i'm so
grateful that but we were a great team
and we were really talented and we i'll
tell you this
we loved xbox it was not a
job it was not like oh well okay we've
we're we work for this publishing
company and i guess
all right we'll do the xbox thing like
no
we all ate slept and breathed xbox
we all loved it dearly i mean frank
o'connor wrote a cover
story on halo 2 wow that was full of so
much passion and enthusiasm
and smart writing and brilliant writing
and that he got hired
you remember frank was one of the first
community managers
he was uh he got hired by bungie and of
course he still works on halo today he
stuck you know he
he left bungie and went to three he
stayed with halo and went to three four
three so
that's awesome we love the platform and
i'll tell you one other quick thing we
took
so much pride in i mean you you couldn't
do this now
because of uh the fact that there are
literally
like 10 plus games a day that come out
through id at xbox
absolutely but we took a lot of pride we
covered
everything wow on the xbox wow we knew
we covered everything we knew every like
we we
just if you asked any game we're like
yep played that we could tell you but
you know it's it's it's impossible now
the volume you should volume now
there's too much but yeah and that's not
a bad thing right now i'm not saying
that's a bad thing
i'm just saying the times have changed
but yeah it's splinter
that we never got a chance to play
remember that one splinter cell the
early build of conviction
yeah did you get a chance to play that
one no i i
i did not the there were a game i mean i
have stories like that but not of the
you're talking about the hobo sam
version yeah the gold the joel
uh sam version yeah i was i was always
very curious about that version and yeah
but never
i never got they never showed it to
right
i guess they didn't show it live to any
you know journalists or anything like
that so yeah never did see that one
because the reason why i asked right is
because i remember that game so vividly
and i was so
i was anticipating the game when i saw
the last of us
and i was like man it's it's something
about this character
that is like like it's something i
couldn't put my finger on it
i played the last of us too and when i
got to you know and did everything
and i was just doing my history then i
remembered the game
right and i was like oh my god
if they would have just went in this
direction what would that direction have
been
with the splinter cell you know and i
just wanted to know if you got a chance
to touch it to see
you know like what it was like i'll tell
you i haven't thought about that
in years till you just brought it up but
you're you know i see where you're going
with that where
i remember the thing about that game
that version of the game was
you were going to like pick up chairs
and objects in the environment to like
throw them at guys and distract and
and you were going to blend into crowds
and stuff and obviously it didn't have
you know zombies or zombie-like
creatures
but yeah there were i guess there were
kind of those there were some some of
those sort of kernel elements of
that kind of like gritty real world
type of uh more grounded approach to it
yeah
absolutely absolutely so yes moving on
to obviously the transition to ign and
the
you know getting in obviously you have
the amazing podcast
unlocked and destin legary lady
miranda sanchez and brandon tyrell who i
missed i i was i get a chance to
talk to but i want to talk about that
you know your transition there and then
of course
your personal passion project the ign
unfiltered it's just an
amazing serious super relaxed super
chill yukon in this one-on-one active
studio
kind of vibe you get laura ryan's got
the tie on you know what i'm saying
he's chilling he's got his guys one tie
i own one
i like the one title the one size smooth
you know it's just like these
really cool stories so like you know i
want to start with the first part with
transition to ign
obviously like my course podcast unlock
and then the third one would be um
igen unfiltered because i want to know
what are some of also the experiences
you got
by doing and things you may have learned
doing these things so let's start from
those
sure yeah so uh yeah they're
unfortunately of course
uh the future itself future publishing
the writing was on the wall things were
not going well
the everybody knew that magazines were
dying
um and so all as all good things must
come to an end i kind of
i eventually got to a point where okay i
guess i
i better start looking around because
i'll tell you the
for for most of that first
five six seven years of my yeah more
than yeah five i would say
six seven because i was there nine and a
half years so i would say maybe the
first
seven years i never even thought about
you a good thought about looking
anywhere else i was i was having again
we i had
i knew i had an incredible team and a
great gig at oxm
and yeah but eventually it came time
where like okay i guess i'd better start
keeping my eyes open here and and it
worked out where
um the editor in chief at the time of
of ign casey lynch i knew from he
had done pr before he ended up at ign he
had done pr
in various capacities including he was a
pr guy for rock band which the oxm team
we were oh my god that's another show
rock band was a phenomenon that i would
i'm telling you
rock band and halo 2 are the two
eras that i would give my like
pinky toe to get back
like they're gone forever and they're
never coming back transforming
because again life changes and things
change but
those two periods were
incredibly just the the experiences and
the memories were
so great but anyway uh so
i uh casey i had i talked to like he was
interested in me and running
and running the xbox channel there uh he
knew he was gonna have an opening
and and it took a little while but over
time like it there was just the mutual
interest and i knew like
all right if i'm gonna leave oxm like i
i i don't
i'm not a nomadic guy i i've i've only
worked at two places and i
i like that i'm i i want to be
comfortable
and happy somewhere i'm not you know
there are people who are who just
yeah they're just they they're like and
they're upping their salary each time
and they're
and it's like full respect that's i'm
not wired that way
i want to be somewhere and stay there
and be comfortable
yes and and i'm very lucky to have that
now at ign as i had it
at oxm right but anyway so yeah i
i did get hired in uh in may of 2012
at ign and uh i that was back when e3
was still in the beginning of
the like super beginning of june and uh
and so my my first i had one day
in the ign office before we left for e3
so my start time was just two years
oh you hit the ground running and i
didn't
i didn't really know anyone uh except
for mitch dyer who had freelance for me
at oxm before ign hired him and
i was actually mitch's boss so that at
least i had mitch
as somebody i knew but none of them knew
me really you know we had the job
interview
and but um so yeah at e3
2012 i was just trying to kind of stay
out of the way
and just contribute where i could but um
yeah i it was feet to the fire for sure
it's kind of the ign way we just throw
you right into the fire
it's like if you burn to a crisp oh wow
but if you emerge like uh
daenerys from the flames like okay
you're a keeper that's a good reference
that's a good one so
uh so anyway uh yeah and and i'll tell
you the first
my first day at ign i said i right away
i grabbed mitch and whoever i forget who
who else was on the show at the time i
said
let's do a podcast right now and i like
i did a sh i did unlocked on my first
day
because the i had started the oxm
podcast
years before so i i'd been podcasting
and i loved it
it's it's scratched i i always uh if i
hadn't got
been lucky enough to get into journalism
and and games media
i probably would have wanted to go tried
to go into radio because i always loved
it
and you know no literally no one's ever
told me
you're a handsome boy because it's not
true
this is what i this is what i got
nothing i can do about it
how but i her i used to hear a lot wow
you've got a great voice you've got a
great radio so
that was the gift that god gave me i
didn't get the face
but i did get the voice so i i always
loved radio i'm a big hou
or i was that's another story though i
was a big howard stern fan for many
years
yeah uh i i really think the show's gone
just
it's it's a shell of its former self now
but that's another topic for another day
but
yeah i was a big stern fan for many
years always
i i think he was the best interviewer in
media
like he would get things out of people
that nobody else would get and
absolutely
so so stern was a big influence on me
and uh and so yeah so i i came right
first day at ign let's do a podcast and
there i changed the format i i basically
i had created
this radio show style format at oxm
because again i grew i grew up loving
radio and wanting to be in radio
so i kind of crafted koxm was the name
of it and
for those of you on the east coast it's
you know your radio stations are
whatever
i don't know where the cutoff is
mississippi river whatever it's it's
the letter is k whatever yeah so we were
out west and
so we i did i called it koxm but anyway
uh so i i purposely wanted it to sound
like a radio show
and and when i got to ign i said all
right i'm gonna
i'm i'm gonna do this on unlocked
and uh the the format before i got there
was it was basically like it was just
four it was kind of the equivalent of
like four guys with beers
yeah at around a card table just like
playing cards and
and you know talking smack and a lot of
people love that so i got a lot of hate
mail for a while like because
because i didn't there was no like i
ripped the band-aid off it was just like
i'm not doing it this way right and
there were a lot of people like get rid
of this guy
he's horrible how big i get it right
like
if you you like something and somebody
comes in and just change it and suddenly
it's changed
so you know eventually those people
either stopped listening and moved on
or they got you know they stuck around
and and still enjoy
that's fine so so yeah i uh i've been
doing unlocked since day one
uh that i got to ign and and then uh
yeah i
uh i i put together
it was e3 well it was before i started i
would say
the end of 2014. okay
the end of 2014 i had this idea it's
like what
i want like it would be really cool
to interview the different
heads of xbox from different eras to
stop together right now
i have to stop you right now because you
literally transitioned into what i was
just about and you framed it perfect you
framed the purpose
so what i got this is in my opinion
one of the magic moments of lord ryan
mccaffrey right
this is if it comes to my mount rushmore
of podcast moments that was was it
podcast unlock
201 i believe right correct yes sir okay
you had three generations of xbox
leadership
lord black you know what i'm saying yeah
my personal favorite lord peter moore
the legendary
and then of course who we call xbox only
begotten son affectionately
feel dominance maximus
thank you go ahead thank you
so here's the thing like you had three
generations of xbox leadership
the interview was absolutely superb
you've got so many gems and jewels and
stories and
trials and tribulations of each going
through the process of leadership
one in particular peter moore's story
where he called the tylenol moment
as far as the red ring of death and
having to go to steve balmer and have
that conversation
it's a billion dollars right sheamus you
know the fight to make
xbox relevant believable you know the
the clowning and things like that
obviously feel the young gun at the time
you know what i'm saying
changing the culture around so like my
thing for you is like
is that your because it's my mom but i
want to know for you
professionally is that your moment as
far as podcasting
pinnacle oh yeah it's not close i will i
will
i i know there's no way i will ever do
anything that good
at i'd be like it's and i like i know
that sounds like
part braggadocious but also part
self-deprecating but like i know like
that was just a special
moment everything came together uh
and i like there's it would be even if i
did like a sequel to that with
with like jay allard and
a couple other guys like it's it's not
going to be that good like that was just
the thing about that was i had the idea
for it
and again like the end of 2014 and you
got to remember too like
that was that was right in the the
throws of the xbox one crisis like
they had launched and it was all a
disaster
it was like the the xbox was on fire
basically like it was just a four alarm
fire
everything was was was going wrong
and but i had this idea like you know
it'd be really cool to sort of
talk through the history of xbox with
these guys because i've been doing
developer interviews on podcast unlocked
for a while just in the middle of the
show like i would just have people
in um to tell their sort of career story
because again
comes back to that howard stern
influence i want to you know howard
would sit down with people for an hour
which you know again was unheard of most
talk shows
you know you're on there for your
12-minute segment or whatever it is
you're telling some stupid pr
story and that's and that's was
entertainment people okay but
but howard was in there like having real
conversations
about where these people came from
and i always thought that was brilliant
and so i was like
i want to do this with because with like
because video games are amazing and we
love them
right but you don't hear about the
people
and how they got to who they are and
how they came to create these things
that always
interested me so i'd started doing these
on unlocked
and and then uh so then i had this idea
about
about the you know these three
generations of xbox heads
and it it i'll tell you you know it's
not easy
so sheamus at the time as he still is
now is was just
that dude is and i say this in the most
complimentary way he's a friend
he's a renaissance man like he has he
has a million different
passions and strengths like he's a
physicist he's a roboticist
he's he's a sourdough bread maker like
he was out of the forefront of this
whole like
you know before quarantine he was he was
out there
making sourdough bread from yeast
cultures in the wild like wow
the guy like it's it's a stat there's
nothing this guy is not
brilliant yeah so like i reached out to
him
he i was able to get on board pretty
quickly because he doesn't work for a
major corporation and is beholden to
a million people and and schedules and
all that all right
let's talk about people and i hadn't uh
and and the re and i had uh
i hadn't met sheamus yet because uh
he i the other idea i had sort of
stealing from television
was uh you know how like at the super
bowl they'll have
they'll have a quarterback from the
league yes who's just not in the super
bowl
sitting in england with the panel
you know with terry bradshaw and all
those guys like helping break down the
game i thought
that would be fun to do at e3 like after
the xbox press conference
let me get seamus blackley in here who's
not beholden to any pr he'll say
whatever's on his mind
so that was the that was the original
idea with him and then that transitioned
into well you know what
while he's here why don't i try to get
you know get these three heads of xbox
so i had sheamus on board
peter was running ea at the time if you
remember oh yeah
yeah and uh so i had to start that
conversation and then
phil yeah at that point i guess yeah he
yeah he had been installed
he had been promoted to the head of xbox
okay so how long would you say he was
that
was that time period from his promotion
no it wasn't long why would you say it
was fairly new
yeah well yeah because he was he was
named head of xbox in the like spring
like march or so of 2014. i looked this
up recently because it did somehow come
up
um so then i'm you know and then this
thing
so i'm reaching out at the end of 2014.
so you know he'd been on the job six
eight nine months gotcha
and so like okay and i'm pitching this
idea and you gotta think like
you gotta fairly look at it from the
other side like if you're microsoft pr
and your your brand is on fire yeah do
you really want to let
the head of xbox sit in with a games
media guy
right uh two four football you know
compe
sitting with the two other guys who's
who's
whose errors of xbox went really well
and your error is going really badly
like you know you gotta look at it
fairly from their side so
anyway it it literally took me six
months of emails and phone calls
and pitching and trying to convince them
i mean to the point a lot can go wrong
yeah i mean it was not a sure thing like
people think oh you know i just i just
picked up the phone and
called phil yeah no it does not work
like that
there are a lot of gatekeepers to go
through for these things
i got everybody on board and
uh and then we shot it during e3 because
because everybody they were all gonna be
in la you know they were all
in there for e3 so i thought okay
we had a we had a remote set okay we
always have a remote base of operations
at e3
so we had a so all right and we're but
we shoot there all day but these guys
are also in meetings all day so
okay let's shoot it at night let's shoot
it after
everybody's stuff is over like seven
o'clock at night or something
and so we we all meet up there
and i had obviously spent months
preparing questions like i had
i had done the work to to get ready for
that
and i had literally if you watch the
interview on video you'll see i have
like literal
i'm i'm like a real newscaster given
pages of stuff
he was working you know and it was okay
if the conversation goes this way i can
go here or you know i kind of had mapped
it out like
this is how i'd like the conversation to
go but i have to be ready to pivot and
move if somebody's doing something
interesting
so the thing i'll say about unlock 201
is legendary that thank you but it
i'll say uh i'm sure that was stressful
man
no it actually wasn't it's funny it i i
was more i was a little nervous before
it started but
this is gonna sound egotistical but i
promise i don't mean it this way
you talk right 20 minutes into it
i like literally i knew i was like this
is the
this is gold like this is the greatest
because you're seeing your work come
together
it's two things i i take some credit
because i was
completely prepared i knew my [ __ ] like
that there's no
like i had all of xbox history in my
head so
nobody better to do that in that moment
so i was prepared but the other half of
the credit
goes to phil peter and sheamus because
they all knew each other a bit and had a
professional respect for each other
that's what i liked too
so they were able like you know it's not
like they were sitting there having
never met each other and like
you're right you're right they added
chemistry
yes exactly they had a chemistry
themselves
which just made my life as the host and
the interviewer 10 times easier
and so my job i and i think
some interviews i don't do a good job of
this but in this interview
i did and that is i
steered the the interview in the way i
wanted to go but i did a good job of
staying out of the way like i i knew i
let these guys just go
like i would just kind of i had some
questions and i was like okay well what
about this and then
i was smart enough to just let them be
the focus
and not and not selfishly try to be the
star of this thing
in other interviews i'm i've not done a
good job of that and i've talked too
much and made it
about me at times and and that's the
thing that i'm always trying to work on
with myself as an interviewer is is
trying to
you know be be a better host and a
better interviewer but
but yeah like unlock 201 that was a
special moment
and then from there that's where
unfiltered came from because i
after that i was like that was fun that
was amazing i should do more of this
yes and that where unfiltered came from
and i pitched it
uh to the ign heads and uh as le
and and to their credit they they green
lit it
and and to this day like it doesn't
really get
a lot of traffic like he pisses me off
that really does
watches hour-long interviews which i get
i mean it is available as a podcast but
it also doesn't even do that great as a
podcast quite frankly
but to to my boss's credit they've let
it go for
four years now because they see the
value in it too
as something for me there's no one else
in the industry is doing this
right no one there's no one doing it and
i don't know why
because it's like there's there's so
many great
developer stories to be had absolutely
and
you know so it's been a point of pride
for me it is my passion project
i am very very aware that it's mostly
white guys
and i i want to change that um
it's tough i will say like i'm not i
want to make an excuse but
what i will say is it's
most of the well-known people that have
these long careers
are white men because that's who's been
given the opportunities
over the last 20 30 years so but it is
it's
so i do want to be better about that it
is something that i'm aware of and
that's
that's i think the most um
fair like you can you can not like me
and think that i talk too much
on this on these things or whatever
that's subjective but i think it's
the the most valid criticism that i that
i
totally respect and share myself is like
yeah it's
there's it's just too many interviews
with white men
right but but that aside i am still very
proud
of it as a bodybuilder i've got like 52
episodes of it now
there's there's like that's like 52 plus
hours
of deep dive career stories
what i wanted to say was when i watched
the
the interviews that you did with with
phil and the team
um what i noticed is and i and
you could tell in early on in the
beginning like you said 20 minutes in
right as as a
uh ex fighter
you did the road work yes you you ate
right you did all that stuff you
you were prepared and then you hit your
ali moment i call it an ali moment where
you get into the zone
and you got into the zone so after that
interview was done
and you got that belt you got that belt
you challenged yourself in the next
arena with the one-on-ones
and i think that is phenomenal
thank you not too many people would ev
the reason why you say not too many
people are doing it
because it's when it's a one-on-one
right it's a loss nobody else to blame
yeah
it's right so a lot of people can't take
that much
pressure so when i watch your
one-on-ones i'm like yeah
he's in his element he's pushing himself
you're pushing his own
that's why the the heads at ign
continue to let it go because you're not
stagnant
at all it's not like you let unlock just
fall to the side exactly
no and lock is still doing its thing
but you're over here right building this
thing
okay so i just wanted to you know
express that's what i
see from that from that eye like you're
in an
element that you know you you've made
this lane you've pushed the bar
up so that's what i took my hat off to
you wanted to say something real quick
yeah uh first i don't want a couple say
that yeah when it comes to you know
podcast unlock 201 like i remember
exactly what i was
doing when someone brought this to white
tits i remember i was playing one of the
halos i don't know if it was before the
master chief collection or if it was
after
so if it was it would have been after
because yeah it was 2015.
yeah so i i was playing one of the games
on there i remember kids smooth jumps at
the party he's like
yo you you seen that podcast unlocked i
was like no
i was like what's going on he's like
dude he had phil spencer and peter moore
he didn't tell the other person but at
that time
but he was like respect to sheamus yeah
he was like he was like he
he had peter moore and phil spencer i
was like he had both of them on one show
he's like yeah man
i ain't never laughed because at the
time i didn't have like a a setup or
anything like that i never brought my
phone up so fast
i was like i want to i want to watch
this and i remember watching that
and like i i remember like there's
certain moments when you watch something
that you was like it depends on you know
how like when you see something on
twitter and if people keep bringing it
up you're like oh this is getting
traction
like i remember people hitting me up
that they had nothing that did they did
not even like xbox it's like did you
watch that
that ryan mccaffrey with the with the
three heads of xbox
like i remember thinking i was like yo
that that's a really good look
and you know when it comes to you know
why you don't think people really get
into
uh into you the um filters i think it
probably has a lot to do
you know it's like king said when it
comes to one-on-ones that's a lot harder
format to make because you can't because
i i'm like the one kind of person that
likes to bounce off people
so it's hard with just one other person
because you ain't bouncing off someone
else
so and i think a lot of it has to do it
was like people aren't as
patient as you are too so like like you
said earlier these pr
teams you know sometimes you have to you
have to whine and die
at the end of the day not to cut you out
just that there's a trust involved right
because
yes we have ign that has to trust ryan
that
that platform that he's doing right and
then the people involved right like like
he said with phil bringing him in
at that time right you know they've got
to protect
phil you know microsoft pr stuff like
that so there's a there's a lot of trust
involved on all sides
and then when it goes off successfully
that then opens the door okay you know
what
we can then have we we have now stamped
ryan right we know he's going to ask
questions but he's also going to be
respectful
he's going to protect some guys in some
some respect and it's never going to
divert into this
old negative connotation kind of a deal
so that's what's against off you want to
say something
yeah i think besides just the fact that
the work that you put into getting them
all in the same room at the same time
the most impressive thing about it is
just
how you manage three very different
personalities because they
are i mean sheamus is is a genius and
sheamus yeah the way sheamus expresses
himself sometimes is like
he's very kind of a cuff very he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
he doesn't he doesn't and then you have
peter that that's a showman like in
everything he does he's
he's very much a showman and then you
have phil who's more subdued
and to have all of these guys and this
is crazy different personality yeah
there's
so many different personalities and be
able to juggle them and to be able to
sort of
extract from them what's what's what
they love most about
their era is something that not everyone
can do it it's some
you know it takes somebody that can take
the reins and sort of direct the
conversation
and at the same time know when to let
them go and to let them just say what
they need to say
and it's not an easy thing to do and
that's why honestly i do think that it
continues for me i love unfiltered
because
i am that guy and these guys as well
like i'm that guy who
i want gamers today the younger
generation to really understand
where all this comes comes from a lot of
a lot of times the younger generation
just they they want the games they want
they want to play the games they want to
talk about the games
but they don't take enough time to
understand what's behind them
and i think as i've gotten older i've
cared more about that because
you you realize these are human beings
making these games and there are a lot
of
interesting stories that come from these
games that a lot of people just don't
listen to double down one quick is that
i think a lot not just younger gamers
even myself as an older gamer
there's a lot of misconceptions we have
about how things work in the industry
so these comments these are the huge
mistakes yeah these discussions that's
what's gonna ask you ryan like
what do you think when you do unfilter
you hear these stories you hear the phil
harrisons you hear
all these people you've had over
generate you just recently had you know
jeff kegley
i was listening to his story was pretty
amazing like what do you think is the
biggest misconception
gamers have about the gaming industry
now that's a good question i don't know
everything
what do we do you know wrong right wrong
about everything
i guess maybe i would say that in most
cases
um and i know i had told you guys 11 30.
i i got i think i got about 15 more
minutes only because i got
i got another thing at the top of the
hour that's otherwise i'd stay with you
guys
uh all day but um yeah maybe i mean
it's it's tough like i don't know if i
would even necessarily answer
that question like it's because it's
i mean games are they are art
but they are also a product but they're
made by humans so it's like
people i mean my my
least my least favorite thing about
the this this year and the next gen
console
uh run up here is just the
the ridiculous console war
trash that poisons my feet on a daily
basis
it's actually the reason why i've i've
started i've done this now
probably four or five weekends in a row
i'm i'm not
i'm just staying off of twitter on the
weekends because you know what i've been
seeing your tweet
i'll be feeling bad i'm like man they
get my boy ryan again
yeah i mean i'm i'm plugged in all day
every day with the work from home and
let me just pause for a quick in a
second and say i'm very grateful to be
able
to work from home and i can continue to
support my family so
i don't want to make it seem like i'm
you know up on some pedestal or anything
like that but
but yeah i mean like i've been taking
twitter breaks on the weekends which has
been really
mentally beneficial for me because it's
yeah it's it's training it's fair
like games are products and it's fair
for people to
criticize them as like all right hey i
paid 60 bucks for this
i'm you know i'm expecting x y and z but
to answer the question about unfiltered
and and misconceptions it's
you know it's i think maybe a lot of
people
might feel again i don't want to blanket
statement this but it seems like a lot
of people
a lot of people out there vocal ones
anyway seem to feel like
that that developers are intentionally
not trying their hardest or
intentionally uh
being grubby with money and putting in
micro transactions or this and that it's
like most of the time
the developers that i'm talking to they
care
every bit as much as you or i care and
usually a heck of a lot more and they
want to make the best
art that they can but there are just so
many other
factors and forces that that cause games
to either not be
as good as you want them to be or to be
buggy or to be to have micro
transaction things that you might not be
a fan of there are
just there are so many i guess it's just
that there are a lot of factors that go
into a game
got it but again i'm not i'm not
defending those
gross practices like there are things
that like yeah like
there are just things that are just just
garbage that should not that are
that are gross and that deserve to be
called out and criticized but
as far as when i sit down with these
developers right
they are people first of all they are
people they don't want to read
they don't want to spend four years on a
game and then go on social media and see
everybody just calling it the worst
thing of all time
you know it's i feel for these people uh
you know it's it's uh like i mean
let's real quick as a quick aside let's
look at halo infinite real fast
it's does it deserve the criticism it's
been getting
yes do i feel bad for 343
yes and you might be sitting there
thinking well why are you feeling bad
for them ryan
they they are the ones that are making
this right
well halo probably shouldn't have been
shown
right right they should they're somebody
somebody at some level should have said
this isn't ready
we can't put this out there yet in fact
they probably somebody should have seen
the delay like the fact that this game
wasn't going to be ready
right so there there's criticism to be
had there i just i
so i i feel bad for the 343 teams that
are
putting in the work and doing their best
to make us a damn good halo game
but you know it was that's fair that's
it being shown in the state it was is is
is you know
the the the the artists the art team
doesn't have any control over when halo
infinite gets shown
right they're making the art but they
you know and they're working on it
but they don't like and suddenly they
just get told well we're showing this at
the
at the july xbox event and they're gonna
i'm sure a few of them were thinking
they're like what
i'm ready so running the best thing that
ever
happened was it was shown right
because in in my opinion i think
everything was tied to this game being
launched right yeah
and if if craig never shows up
you know and trust me i didn't know
anything about it i was just like
blindsided by craig the next day yeah um
and it needed it
you know um and phil stood on his word
the game will go into cooker and it will
come out when it's ready right and it
was a lot of marketing and stuff tied to
this game
so if if if it's not shown or if they
try to cover up something and then they
release it and try to fix it later then
we have a halo master chief type of
thing
and that's something that can't be fixed
once it's out you know i
i agree with you but i'm i think i'm i
i'm saying we're both right i
totally agree with you but i'm i feel
like they shouldn't have been put in
that
position
we're not ready right we need to a not
show this and b
we need to delay this thing because
you look at like take a look just to i
know i just got done railing about how
i can't stand the console war stuff but
right but like just
to compare look look at what sony how
sony handles
their business right like they and
this is you know so this is a bit of a
criticism of microsoft
microsoft is arguably too honest
at times which i know as a media guy i
shouldn't say that because
like i value that like i myself am an
honesty is the best policy person
i'm not i don't i don't like to lie it's
not i don't do it
it's it's honestly it's i believe
because it's gotten me to this point
like
i i if i were a a decep a deceptive
deceitful
liar kind of guy i probably wouldn't
have gotten the three heads of xbox in
the same room because
actually to your point that trust
wouldn't have been there if i were a guy
that
if that's just who i was not to know
that nothing
funny was gonna right but i'm not gonna
i'm not there to throw them all under
the bus
and but yeah but yeah like like i
for all we know spider-man the you know
the other
marquee launch title on the other
platform of course
until halo's delayed now but for all we
know like
maybe spider-man's been in a like
because we haven't
even seen any gameplay you never know it
it's all because it's all being handled
behind the scenes correct
so it's just like good points the leader
you know there are
whether it's insomniac or up higher at
sony like
and you just you know the last of us
too went through some of this stuff but
that was
that wasn't really that was more just
about uh
that was kind of a leak that wasn't
really like whereas microsoft has been
stepping on the rake
volume like voluntarily like oh look
there's a rake i should probably avoid
hit me in the face you know what i think
i can make it through and i'm going to
avoid
was carrying the rock that you throw in
front of yourself and trip on
like you're actually walking with the
rock and you're just it's it's like
you're trying to get some insurance
fraud just throws the rock and just
trips on it like
when it comes to like the whole twitter
thing and like i've always have
you know i've been in other poc has been
very vocal it's like look like
you can criticize while being respected
suspect
that's the thing if people tell me they
can't they lying
because i know you can't because i'm one
of the vocal and be respectful
that's that's my job right like and i
get
you know i feel like i'm pretty good at
my job
in that yes i get people that say you're
an xbox fanboy you're paid off by
microsoft
but then all your tesla's coming in i
get i get plenty of other people that
are like
you hate xbox yes
well that tells me that i'm right where
i need to be factually because
i i i have and i mean i'm doing it on
this show i'm constructively criticizing
microsoft
i do that all the time on unlock because
guess what as you guys well know
because you're talking about you're
addressing this very thing it's like
if you just endlessly praise
if you fan if you go full fanboy and you
just
you just say everything this plastic toy
manufacturer does
is amazing and i pledge my undying
fealty to them
to go with the full iron lord i'm gonna
give you an event
if you if you do that guess what
they will first of all your word will
become useless
because you will never criticize them
and two
they'll never get better when they do
screw up because all they hear is
well our fans love everything we're
doing we're just gonna keep doing it and
you know
last question and we got to do the
classic top five with you but um
the last question look at the end of the
day first of all that was amazing what
you said
um the thing i gotta say is that i feel
personally like your diligence as far as
just making
ign this ally this this champion for
content creators of color
like i really want to salute you because
in my opinion obviously we know a lot of
things going on in the world today
it's been it's been really rough out
there but what i felt is there was a lot
of
hashtagging in the moment right and it's
cool
don't get me wrong we respect it but one
thing i have to salute you is that
you have kept ign's feet to the fire
as far as being consistent and still
going on and doing that with your
programming obviously you had the
brother um neo neo game spark who we've
had in the realm before
you know paris m.c fixer who we saw
earlier you know these these content
creators of color that most people don't
get a chance to see so
i want to salute you for that but my
question to you is why do you
still feel it's so important to keep
that going
because well you know what i'll let me
answer selfishly
and you know people are gonna be like
okay let's where's he going with this
it's so yes it's important and it's it's
it's like like my show unlocked is
three white guys and a latina woman and
that's
that's something like okay yeah we have
a latino
okay that's you know we could
we could say we're diverse if we stop
and call the day right there right
but this i mean i
just i have looked inward like i i put
up a big
like notepad twitter post about this
you know when when all the george floyd
stuff was was first kind of
really bubbling up and like i looked at
myself i
i looked inward like obviously i'm like
the whitest white guy there is
it's like the joke but what i looked is
see
the thing is i realized my i i have had
the whitest upbringing not in any
malicious way
right not in like a you know it's not
like my parents didn't want to be near
people of color but i'm originally from
vernon new jersey
which is a which is a especially in the
80s
and i think this is actually still the
case but it's just it's just a
very it's an overwhelmingly white
community right and that's just
you know i mean it's all systemic right
it's it's
it's white because you know that that's
you could keep digging
and there are reasons for that they're
really but that's where i'm from
and then my family uh moved to
mesa arizona or before
uh my a lot of my extended like
basically my mom is is from a big
catholic family
and a lot of the those brothers and
sisters from that family so my aunts and
uncles
they they all got sick of the the jersey
winters and they wanted to go
west as a lot of people did in the late
80s and so they settled in
mesa arizona and it just turned out that
i mean mesa arizona
extremely white population right
and again it's not from our family's
part it's not a malicious thing
uh it's that's but that's just but
that's what it was what it was
and when i when all like i just started
thinking about that when
when the protest started and uh
because you know you could say well you
know of course i i'm i'm
not racist and i'm not but it's like
well hold on let's
i've just i've been around nothing but
white people it is
that's the norm i look at my look at
podcast unlocked like it's three white
guys
and miranda that's like well okay
i unlocked is what i can control right
i uh i am i am actually not a
hiring manager at ign i'm always in the
conversations when those things happen
but it's not
i don't hire people but unlocked
week to week it happens every tuesday i
control that
for better for worse if you don't like
unlocked that's on me
right if you like unlocked sure that's a
big part i'm a big part of that but
but i have contr i control podcast
unlocked
and so i thought okay well
it's it's it's it's no problem for me to
like we're all working from home anyway
i have i have no excuse there's no
logistical reason
there's no excuse why i cannot when you
know what because
the thing is you know we get busy at ign
i almost every week or often enough
one of them will slack me from unlocked
and say
i got a meeting i'm sorry i can't make
unlocked this week
and you know and in the past i would
just say all right well we'll just do
the three of us it's fine we'll just
we'll just go
but now it's well okay
great here's an opportunity why don't i
invite a black voice on
because we don't we don't have enough of
that at all right we hardly have any of
that
and so uh you know i
just that's where it started and and
it's
it is important that it's not a it's not
a like just because
june ended right doesn't mean that
should stop like
we're still working from home i still
have no excuse and here's
where i'm coming back around uh before i
duck out here to the
to the selfish part right the selfish
reason why
i want to keep it going there's i mean
and i don't i don't want this to sound
like
i'm being selfish like i want to do it
for the right reasons
and i hope that my actions are showing
that i'm doing it for the right reasons
and i
but but what i have realized as
the longer this has gone on whatever you
learned
is that unlocked is actually
better because of your voices it's
better the show is better it's
you know when we have paris on when we
have
you on when we have uh neogamespark
on an mc fixer and and cicero homes
and and all these guys when we have
these people
on like they just have
a complete like i don't work with them
and so like they've just got their
own not only their own life story but
just their own
like i don't work with them every day
they're not seeing all the same stuff i
see
they just have a unique perspective and
it's and i'm not just talking about the
black perspective although that's vital
as well
it's just their own just their life
their gaming perspective and where they
live and who they who their friends are
and what they're playing and that
i have just had so much fun and i think
unlocked has been so much better
because of those perspectives and
because of those voices but
but yeah so it's it's awesome that's the
selfish reason but yes it is also
important
right as as a person who has looked
inward and seen that
i've been surrounded by nothing but
white people my whole life that
that that's not that's not that's not
good right that's not i mean it's again
it's not maliciously bad i'm not saying
i hate white people i'm not saying
anything like that
but it's it's i it's i have not
had the perspective that that needs that
i need to have like it's
i want to hear from the black community
i want to learn from that and we should
like if we all did that if we all
learned from the black community and the
latino community and the asian american
community like
we'd all be better off if we just just
talked to each other and understood each
other better and i know that's like
that's like sounds like a cheesy bumper
sticker thing to say but no
i don't know it's just that's me looking
inward and just saying
i want to be better you're doing it and
i salute you thank you so much
you know ryan being an another fellow
white person like
i respect you a lot
because you know the the racist white
people are the the
vocal ones you know and i like seeing
other white people
that you know break that vocal that you
know they're vocal for good
reasons not bad reasons because you know
when i get on twitter and i see
all this racist stuff going on twitter
i'm like man
another person making my whole race look
bad
but then you got on the opposite
spectrum you got
you you know inviting people on your
platform getting more of a diverse
uh a diverse audience you know
you're bringing in people giving them a
voice you're showing people and you're
giving people exposure
and i have to respect that because you
know one of the things that iop was
built on is you know we want to build a
platform to you know
help help students small studios give
them voices to help
smaller content creators give them
voices and and i like someone from ign
you know arguably the the most popular
gaming division out there that you're
giving
other people a platform and i really
respect that
absolutely and the final point because i
know you got to go but at the end of the
day
you know what i respect about it and
what i respect about
what you're doing and what we're trying
to do as far as our platform is we
want to get different voices if you
listen to the same thing or you surround
yourself around the same people all the
time
how can you learn how can you improve
right and one of those things
which is really cool is listening
whether it be ethnicity religion
sexuality politics
none of that doesn't matter at the end
of the day we're all gamers we do have
this common bond
that we share that is what should be
most important
right and again i gotta commend you
because
i love what you're doing i love to see
the different
people i'm learning about you know that
i didn't even know you know i mean also
our female content creators things of
that nature we
all can improve it's it's very important
i gotta salute you on that
we gotta get you out here because i know
it's because you gotta let him go but
let's
let's let's get his top let's get his
top five he's gotta give him the three
traffic topic that he's on and he's out
yeah all right so classic we asked this
all around all right i need lord ryan's
kind of gave us a preview
top five video games or franchises of
all time
all right yeah this is a tough one
because you know when you've been gaming
your whole life like a lot of us have
it's uh
it's a long list but i mean uh
super mario brothers but not one hold on
three mario brother i'm a three guy
three over
i'm a three over world okay i respect
super mario world but i'm a three guy
three was uh three was just incredible
um
super mario brothers three doom
and i'm talking 1993 not 2016 although
yeah
i love 2016. uh
halo 2 my man again
love halo 1. any great memories in the
off in the oxm
office capture the flag but
what again i told you earlier if i could
go back in time to the halo
2 and that moment it changed the game
brother continue
all right uh diablo 2 i said also
earlier in the interview
it's unbelievable i mean i
would do lan parties with my buddies and
stay up all night playing diablo too
so many great memories of that game
mm-hmm and gosh it's uh it's tough to
pick a fifth
um leisure shoot larry no johnny
no you know what i'll give you i'll say
um i'll actually say because again
another show i managed to reference like
uh i would say grand theft auto 3
or or even just the franchise maybe go
franchise on that
three was the one that changed you know
that was a paradigm shift for me
four i love but i think five though i
think five is one of the
greatest video games of all time like i
have the memories of three because it
just changed it just rocked my world
completely but
five is just to me and incre like it is
a top
probably 10 all-time video game period
so yeah grand theft auto is definitely
in the in the conversation all right
and yeah go ahead the
it's either the original xbox or the 360
but i don't know which one
um uh
you know what uh probably the 360.
three sixties
effect halo
the list goes on and on and on with the
360.
absolutely lord ryan an absolute
pleasure to have you in the realm of the
lord
and honor i know you went ot you got a
lot of stuff please if they don't know
they gotta know now where can the fine
people find you in the room
and what else do you have going on uh if
you're interested in uh follow me on
twitter it's at
dmc underscore ryan that's because it's
not devil may cry
i used to own a delorean my dream car as
a kid that's another story
that we didn't have time for but uh dmc
underscore ryan
yeah and then show wise it's it's
unlocked every tuesday
uh usually it's late late tuesday by the
time it posts uh so maybe you catch it
wednesday morning
there's unfiltered every month or so and
then uh
on my passion project on the side i'm
into big tesla guy
i do a weekly tesla podcast called ride
the lightning
and i had it i did a one hour talking
about like you know big interviews
i got to interview elon musk for an hour
the new york times can't even say that
wow i got elon for an hour so if you're
you can always if you're curious
what the heck that's like that was
episode 200 which was an awesome
coincidence
oh that's awesome brother thank you so
much
thanks for having me it's been an honor
you being on the show
especially watching you for so many
years uh you know
being on the show never would have
thought we would ever have you on the
show this
you made our bucket list
[Laughter]
hit me up was like guess who might come
on something right i was like no you
lying
you lying why are you playing with me
like that brian like i said pleasure
you always welcome in the land of the
rebel the lord you already know him
enjoy your sunday brother thank you so
much
gentlemen thank you so much thank you
have a good week you have a nice time
all right bye-bye guys
before i get into the super chats a few
things first
apologies to the guys in the chat who
had direct questions for ryan
we had to sort of just let it keep going
because if we kept stopping to do super
chats we weren't
going to be able to we were on a super
time limited schedule with him exactly
and he was kind enough to stay he
actually stood
and then point number two anybody who
thinks they can jump into our chat
and say negative things and see you're
getting sniped
you're getting sniped and if you feel
the need to have to
pay a super chat to say what you want to
say that's getting started thank you for
your intervention
but thank you though thank you
it's messy thank you for the super chat
we're not reading it but thank you
like i said you you have to understand
one thing you know
um not for nothing he's trying his best
exactly so if
if if if you feel he's right or he's
wrong
he's trying his best right and you know
you take your fanboy stuff
to the side just throw it to the bushes
you know
people and boy stuff is one thing listen
to people we're just being rude
and it's like i've always said you know
i got into some discussions a couple
uh out like two or three days ago about
right it's like look like at the end of
the day
it you can you can feel how you want to
feel by right but he's a
he's a human being and he's got the
right to have different thought process
than you guys do
so the main thing is is like we always
said we got to be respectful y'all
yeah you can criticize without being
distracted once you cross okay and i see
racist comments and all that that's all
they're going to get
but these super chats
and people in the chat i saw you guys
being messy
saying oh yeah yeah i wanted
to go on i was like now thinking about
it it was kind of hilarious
it said something different but i wasn't
meaning
in the chat thank you lord burns for
joining the realm of the whole
team let me get so this one just popped
up i'll read it first yeah gamer by
choice with the 20
super chat salute to the lords for
always having great shows
and awesome guests you are worthy of our
respect thank you
thank you so much now let me get into
this very long list let's go
spiderman speederman's
unlock was the first podcast i ever
listened to thanks to ryan i watch
every week if you ever leave ign will
you still do a gaming podcast
unfortunately we weren't able to ask him
that if anything we will try to get a
lot of these messages
to ryan just to show him the love of the
people showing them in the description
all right um so next up we have perfect
shogun with the five dollar super chat
everybody go and lock that like button
welcome to the realm ryan
thank you for your consistent work at
ign and for amplifying black creators
absolutely absolutely then we have
midway monster with the two dollar super
chat
did not so i guess this is in regards to
getting the three heads of xbox in the
room he said
donnie d or donnie m yeah i saw that
question i wanted to ask him but he was
in his bag
because i was like didn't get that
invite
[Laughter]
i wanted to we just didn't have time
yeah that would have been that would
have been a funny flower
then we have jonathan b with the 2l
super chat talk that talk lord ryan
hashtag
on god and now yes yes
then we have lord brat with the 2 super
chat ryan love the work you're doing
salute
and we have our brother 108 dragons tv
with the 5 super chat
what's up lords i enjoy this podcast
just as much as i enjoy
watching power
super chat this generation of gamers cry
about everything
it's so much to wear even if they have a
valid point it's overshadowed by
crybabies who don't get it which is true
absolutely echelon seven the darkness
with the five dollars the chat
hold on i'm actually reading uh uh
emojis hold on
iron lords and ryan uh what's up
impossible dream
xbox acquisition rockstar cd projekt red
or someone else
that's something we'll have to ask him
kids move with the five dollar super
chat
had to step away for a bit did y'all ask
ryan about the whole xbox series x held
back comments unfortunately we couldn't
get to anything
no the interview was just so lit we
couldn't have done
uh then we have eternal shadai with the
ten dollar super chat
sony is the market leader that is just
facts for microsoft to be at their level
this gen
do you think aaron greenberg needs to be
replaced to make marketing
better you know well in answering that
question
let me answer that for you i'm
i'm going to tell you because you don't
know him
uh personally all right so and i don't
know him
hanging out and drinking beers or
something like that but um from what
i've uh
ascertained being in his circumference
uh on numerous occasions the man is
genuine
now at some point in time you remember
it's not just aaron aaron has a whole
team
and there's a whole team that sits down
there's a whole team that does marketing
if you don't like the direction that
microsoft is doing with marketing
then don't complain when they do great i
mean don't don't um give them accolades
when they're doing great things because
not too long ago they were on a roll
remember microsoft has hit their stride
i think they turned it all around you
know the part that annoys me about that
he was the same person
in that place when he was giving them
the praise keep the same praise just
stay the course
sorry you know the part that annoys me
about that like look i get it you know
from the outside look in it it does look
like you know in terms of marketing
microsoft does drop the ball a lot but
it's just like
when none of us know anything about
marketing we don't know how we don't
know the ins and outs
we don't know how well yeah we don't
know any marketing but
it's it's a whole different book you
know
it's a multi-billion dollar corporation
we don't even know if aaron greenberg
has ball
i'm sure he's got bosses but we don't
know how that the anarchy goes
we don't know anything about that like
like
i got i do got an issue it's not even
just with this like people do
too much back seat talking yeah
we got back seat developers they never
developed them probably don't even know
what c
crosstalk is you know you know at the
same time
you know these people are spending their
hard-earned money and
i get it it's just betting on a horse
that you want to see win
it's like you want your piece of plastic
to be the best plastic and get it you
know you want it to shine
i and i i totally get it and i
completely understand it
but this is how you can walk away from
that hole
betting all your chips in one bowl buy
everything
that's it yeah we got it next one let's
see
we haven't started the show we have rise
and grind with the five dollars super
chat thank you for the super chat you
could say something if you want to
brother
then we have the ash and luca with the
five dollars that your boy is showing us
love
thank you lucas yo what up luka loka
what's up then we have philly eagle with
the five dollar super chat salute to
ryan it's not the upbringing that's
problematic it's inability to look
inward you being able to look inward
without without pandering is amazing
that's a great thing to say that
absolutely gamer by choice with the five
dollars which
the hardest thing in the world is to
look inward and see opportunities for
improvement salute to ryan i hope
the rest of the world can do that too
well said
uh that's what it do baby with the 10 oh
my god
let's go great show thank you thank you
then we have drunken ninja with the two
dollar super chat love seeing platforms
coming together
ign and ilp that's right coming together
for
ultron and we have one bad mother with
the five dollar super chat
ryan and iop great seeing class acts
getting together
great to see people who celebrate each
other and seeing the hobby bring people
together
facts then we have the great wall of
bill bill stillwell with the five dollar
super chat
great to hear from ryan fantastic
interview of course because you know the
boss
um we got jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat quick question can we
have addict where a members only
[Laughter]
texas alex with the two dollar super
chat great show guys thank you salute
then we got spotlight with the four
pound jack this is incred this is an
incredible podcast
made by sunday also it's great to see so
much mutual respect amongst you all
stay safe respectful chat dudes like a
train did that girl on the board
wow yeah
twitter fingers dudes need to stop
thanks for your donation exactly thank
you for the donation but you will not be
getting ready
exactly then we have lord brat with the
2000 super chat [ __ ]
check i got i got you bro yeah i just i
i can't bro
it's just crazy
i just i just want to point out we don't
have a whole lot of time i don't think
we can go through
the rest of the topic very effectively i
think we need to pick
one to two and just stick with that hey
look
we we already know what the the 3d
all-stars joint is right
yeah we know you know let's just just do
i mean that's kind of right for some
funny comments it's kind of funny though
but it's like um look tgs we can breathe
look t
atl man first thing switch topic gotta
go
we got we got bouncy boom with the final
super chat thanks interview guys great
show
we have one away once again with the
five dollar super chat shout out to
addict the lead member of the great
poupon club
you know what you know just because you
said that one
bam you're out of control so we all
great yeah we're caught up
we'll decide a minute let me just get
the paul joined from last week um i'll
be clear
that probably but i want to talk about
anti-consumer
we could be the tgs we could fly because
at the end let's just do tgs next week i
mean
yeah look at the end of the day all
right so last week four results
in people spoken to the question after
the recent gameplay show we didn't even
do
um which ps5 title has you most excited
for the playstation 5 launch
the winner at 42 are the damn messy
lords
i don't care all this greatness but
y'all still got halo infinite craig all
up in your mouth
coming in a second at 24
was miles morales is still the de facto
playstation 5
in third place at uh 18 with ratchet
clank showcase uh ssd and playstation 5
next generation
features the best and last place at 14
was demon souls or a secret exclusive
title yet to be revealed group
we already know the jokes about the
craig so we gonna move on
oh all right xbox tokyo game show attic
what's up bro
xbox go to tokyo game show what do you
guys expect um i'll jump in
look i think a lot of people trying to
minimize it
i understand because they said no next
generation news people
feel away um but that doesn't mean it's
not going to be a good show
right i i think that you know that for
me the
their presence there is still
significant i think it's very important
that they're there
um makes a statement it makes a
statement they're going to be there for
a long time as far as an hour and a half
i believe it is
look at the end of the day yakuza like a
dragon
dragon quest on um jrpg on in game pass
all this stuff
these are big deals the past generation
they missed out on these games these are
extremely important games
to diversify your portfolio and honestly
even if there's no next generation news
and all that stuff there
if like you said uh attic me and you
talked offline if they can get a persona
uh a game like persona
you know what i'm saying all these games
that they missed you know what i'm
saying
and what i own personal would be a what
i ultimately like from it honestly
is if you can't get another exclusive uh
you know
japanese game over there then start to
cultivate that studio culture
try to cultivate a studio over there get
your own little in-house young talent
that's what i would ultimately so i love
that they're not giving up on the region
so that's what i got
which you guys saw in king um for me
it's just the fact that they're starting
off the show they're going to be there
that long
obviously it's a little disappointing
you're not going to necessarily but
the fact to me what they need to focus
on is like
cox said bringing these these other
franchises that they haven't brought to
game pass yet into game pass
making the japanese version of game pass
appealing to that market
and i also think again it is a pipe
dream to think that that
console per se is ever going to be
successful there they need to push x
cloud
big time that is how you have you get
that japanese market to even look
that way is if you given something
compelling in terms of xcloud in terms
of packaging or whatever the case may be
any deals they might have with
with with phone makers over there
whatever they can do
to make that something special for that
market
and focus on that portability i think
they need to do
let me get this five dollars to pick out
real quick oh my god oh geez man let me
scroll up
we gotta find out super chat from jd
gamer it is possible that my
is it possible that microsoft will
reveal a new japanese studio acquisition
after all that's for next-gen stuff and
what if it's from software or level five
jd gamer if it's from software
you're gonna wanna bail me on twitter
because i'm going to be so messy
that people are blocking me ridiculous
[Music]
we have squirrelly down with the five
last super chat cox sounded like a rep
for wu-tang financial with the diversify
your bonds
they said no new next-gen info that
doesn't mean they couldn't announce
something next-gen before the show
truly and during the show it would not
be new
she got five dollar super chat from
stitch time
ryan is gone add it go put on your
uniform
all right now look look next week it
would be the overall
the hack last week i couldn't do it
because the camera is messed up got a
new camera hey guys
this week we had ryan on and i don't
care what you
king demanded you do it in front of you
whatever you guys say
on the show before i do that thank you
addicts world in the building
we all caught up yeah all right
what's up man tg all right so um
i think they're lying i really do you
got an hour show you got an
hour you got an hour blocked out
nintendo's not there
and then sony's not dead first of all
this is just
they they don't care about
clyzel gave up
actually addict is black it's just that
seeing him through the tcl makes him
work
you're ridiculous i'm just
i'm speechless but that dude that is the
highlight of the show
game will be in his bag look at the next
super chat man oh my god
jd gamer with the five dollar super chat
what if they announced
uh that they licensed konami properties
like castlevania and metal gear
what if they announced a quadruple a
studio built relax
relax brother you're gonna caught you
fellaini all right okay so anyway
they have one hour on this show i looked
at it and i'm like okay one hour to say
what nothing
so that that's not gonna happen
nintendo's not there
sony's not there they don't care about
their home state why because they feel
like they got it like that
right so you got the little boy that got
to come in and he got to make a lot of
noise so when he's there i think
a lot of these games that are that
haven't been on the
xbox platform will be there in game pass
day and day and then they will tell them
to pull out their app
and you know the game pass app is on
your samsung televisions
and and they will start to push that
narrative of xcloud and show how the
xcloud works
because in order to penetrate that kind
of market
you have to do it a little bit
differently than you've been trying
you know so i just will they show next
generation stuff
no but will they when they talk about
opening
up uh uh new studio in tokyo maybe so
you know so you really have to look at
the the wording on things
and that one hour doesn't sit right with
me because one hour
is a hell of a long time and it's like
you know i was telling kid smooth like
okay i think it's going to be something
big but not to the western audience it's
going to be something big to the
japanese
he said like you know the moment saw
that
man he was already over he's like man i
got a little game show
they're actually broadcasting it only in
general only in japan yeah
yeah so it's it's for them and
and it should be right you know at some
point in time you're supposed to
wherever your weakness is you have to
make it your strength
so i'm not going to say that it's for no
reasons a lot of people told them to
give up on it and i and i understand
phil won't do that so
let's let's finish off absolutely
you guys said everything i said let's
time time time
all right moving on i think i am up yeah
man oh we got a super chat are we good
now we're good all right cool so yeah
look like i'm up so luck man nvidia
and pierre man out here in the streets
there's some announcements
some new cars the rtx 3090 3080 and 3070
with release date specs performance and
pricing
so um yeah man they've been unveiled
they look like absolute monsters
out here we got the lowest spec i
believe which is the 30
70. and now that for according to the
initial
i don't say benchmarks or sort of but
they're saying it's literally gonna look
like it's outperforming the rtx 2080 ti
and king has a fraud alert light
and i don't know what's going on but i'm
just reading the news while he's got the
fraud alert like on
the ed anderson yeah
bye-bye blocked three three
i'm going to let you set it up since you
are in agreement that you did this is
clearly fraudulent i don't know why you
think this brother i'll let you go
the police know it's fraudulent
big navy shout out to big
navy it ain't done until big navy gets
up
oh you dude i'm sitting here talking
about it's about to be on twitter later
on today
this is this at 30 80.
oh my god the 39
yeah yeah yeah big navi when big navy
say something then you all listen
so wait until amd get a hold of it
shake it up and mix it up cause i
remember you saying goofies
all that drinks just to clarify you
called them goofies
that's right slow-mo on your neck he
said big daddy gonna
look like little timmy in a few months
and then amd came out and said hey how's
your performance
are you having performance issues
and tell you what it is then we gonna
know when it truly begins
because all you do is out here i have
never seen so much happen
in my whole life it's been capping from
everybody dudes they don't even have a
pc yo did you hear about that
why are you on my timeline over there
yo i'm telling you right now the next
generation consoles need to be afraid
the way they be talking king like
this these these 30 series will do
anything in your life
you need you you need your clothes
washed they got you
you need to watch tv they got you you
need to get rid of that baby mama they
got you
but you know what emp said right
yeah he's savage man so uh addict uh are
you how do you feel about these cards
sir
man i still need to get me uh a fraud
alert i i need to get me a friend
like like the community's being
ridiculous like
i i literally made a post and i was like
look they're cool
i got a 1080 ti shout out to uh you know
to forte for giving me a great deal on
it and it's like
like the performance of you know the pc
isn't the issue for me
like it is the cheating on the platform
that's the issue with me
uh people cheat on destiny this is an
issue with me
people cheat on fall guys this is an
issue with me and guess what
a 30 90 isn't fixing that right
okay i get it people are excited people
want better performance but at the end
of the day
you're not going you didn't even max out
the 20 series
right like you just but you're not
impressed with the
with the price versus performance
options that they i mean these
these i mean it's cool it's definitely
they're making it more
cheap to get into the because in my
personal opinion
this is a straight press down on pc
on consoles they're like look like we
got a lot of people that probably have
mid-range tears right now you know they
run around with the 1060 stuff like that
like it you don't have to go to the
console
please guys don't leave us like look
here we got you a 500
card like just just pick this up like
you know you might have to upgrade your
your power supply we get that we get
that
but don't leave us man just get this
pretty much you feel it's a play
and it's cool i'm glad that you know
especially how they're being competitive
in price range they've been
crazy crazy with prices i'm glad that
they're starting to be more competitive
price range but it's like
to me the power of these cars have never
been the issue it is what is happening
on steam that is the issue
i love destiny and i'm going to the
series
x because the the cheating has gotten so
bad on there
that if you play charles of osiris it's
an automatic l if you're not cheating
almost yeah
automatic l and it's like you can give
me a card
that runs like that that runs like 18 of
my series x's
and if it doesn't have the the
infrastructure that these consoles have
to stop
as much cheating as possible right it's
it's irrelevant to me
and that and i i have an issue with
people acting like five hundred dollars
is the only thing you need
it's like they're going around the
narrative like you gonna plug the card
in you're gonna plug the card into it
i'm like look like cool you can build a
pc that's stronger than the xbox series
x
and the ps5 for way cheaper than you
could but stop acting like it's 500
because it's not i feel that you have to
buy a case to put this thing in
you have to buy ram to put this to put
you with it
you have to buy cpu you have to buy a
fan you have to almost d
people call me out saying that i'm
trying to convince people not to get uh
not to build a pc shout out to erica
ain't nothing to get to erica but you
know she she did that and i know he was
going to get back to us why i wanted to
make sure there's no b
we like lady erica it's just like like
look like
dollars if people assumed i was saying
that no that is not what i
spoke you just corrected what you said
okay it's like i was not trying to act
like yo
don't build a pc i was saying i was
trying to keep people informed
yo you need more than more than just
that
okay let me get stitch real quick quick
quick
quick
quick
quick
quick
quick quick quick quick check can those cards
make the tcl's any better
thank you for being here
your feelings and peers out here moving
and shaking brother
you know how i feel like i i when i saw
that i've been saying for a while that
i'm bit
i haven't built the tower in a while oh
it's about that time
um so you see master race talk you gotta
go yeah
man you don't even need guns anymore you
just get that 30-90 and you can
but no i mean what what's most
impressive about this right a lot of
people were underwhelmed with the 20
series
because what we got there was the
introduction of
individual hardware for ray tracing and
learning i hate to cut you but ladies
and
gentlemen
we gotta clarify because we don't do
beef in the realm she said lately
i've already talked to her about it i'm
instigating shut up this is
shut up this man addict took my words as
i singled them out excuse me
all i know erica is when i was watching
your stream
you brought up my name a lot that's just
me you know
like to me you got to like look
i know erica like there's one thing i've
always said about erica eric can say the
most slimy
stuff known to me language and i
wouldn't and i wouldn't take it offense
because i know erica
at the court is a very peaceful woman
and she's not trying to go out in here
yeah he needs to hold me that's the home
he's a little
uh did we get the tcl one did you get
those cards
okay so we have one away dragon the 5
super chat the 30 70 is the most
important card
because great performance at a decent
price fashion more peeps can reach the
goal
and that's what gamers should look at
factually that is that's true level i
think for that price point
just fired up going to sweat right
through his members
i think you guys are being messy with
this members only
you're not made here you think you think
you hear of the white delegation you
know it's so messed up
you don't even know what a member's only
oh judged god so yeah back to my point
like to me the price point is where they
really sort of surprised me and
nvidia's never been known for for giving
you reasonable price points
even at the 30-90 range the 30-90
wow let me read this basically said
watch how you speak on my name he really
got his memory going on
wow
you know what i'm doing right now
he's muted his way we got him we got him
good all right we got about
so for me even the 30 90. there's
never been a titan card titan level card
released
for any less than two grand and you're
talking 1500
so even at that super high end they're
still coming in considerably lower why
is your face in the camera like that
continues though wow
so for me it's kind of it's it's compel
this all this argument about
oh the xbox series stop it stop it
they did they're two different honestly
they're completely different lanes
if you were somebody who also had a
great pc and all you need to do
is is is upgrade your gpu then it might
be a compelling argument right
over the next gen consoles if not stop
it you're just trolling
it's not a real argument that you're
having um they're two different two
different markets two different yeah
completely the only choice look at that
i am excited because they've never come
in at this type of price point
and this power this sort of power delta
like 80
percent increase over the top end right
now is kind of bonkers
oh see got the fraud in our songs
leaving us king with the fraud
take why you get the firmware kick the
reason why i'ma say this right here and
i hear you everything no no i just want
to say one thing because i don't want to
take nothing else on the topic
i love everything that you just said amd
always comes in and slice the kneecaps
off with the price
always so i know what day prices
are amd is gonna come in and
slice the kneecaps and i've i've read a
few articles saying that amd
was taken was blindsided
by by these prices they were like what
hold up
i do think that you know i do think this
was a direct attack on consoles i don't
think this has nothing to do with
anything but the question
is can amd even compete with this level
amd is too busy putting intel out of
business i don't care about her
before so yeah they with their cpus it's
a different story but i
i'll say this i need to see what the
3090 does
in performance in terms of 4k one twenty
four
getting this thirty ninety yeah i
where's cat daddy when i need him i can
watch that 30-90 son
get himself but i was if if the
performance is not at least 30
over the 30 80 in 4k 120 and up
then i probably won't do the 30 90. okay
um
if it is for me there's a compelling
argument
that's what i'm saying hold on let's get
some slow ball go right quick
master base is in the building slow
motion a side effect to the 30 70 prices
to use market if for
if a 500 30 70 gpu is still too
expensive for a pc gamer
you can get a used 2080 for 350 to 400.
this eliminates the need to make further
upgrades yes because i'm coming for all
y'all 2080s
oh
about you know these cards it's not even
the cards come out it's how cheap i'm
about to pick up
i'm about to eat right now let's go what
else we got what else we got songs um
then we got 108 with the 5
super chat mostly is going to run out
and get these cards and it's going to
choke the budget pcs from best buy
and then they also have to get an hdmi
2.1 monitor yeah you got to get the
right monitor
on the monitor side actually i
pre-ordered um there is a company called
eve yeah um that is developing a it's
it's a crowd-sourced
monitor so it's not it's not like
crowdfunded but
the tech going into it is from a variety
of different likes you know it's very
tcl-ish
no no no no no it sounds like a variety
of parts
in the building yeah
i'm gonna need you to sit up in your
chair before you fall over when we have
to call you
you say y'all want all your money put it
all in the basket
let's see what type of tv
hates too i'm sorry but yeah it's nice
not at all not yeah i'm going to blow up
away what you guys have
samsung c9 i mean what is it isn't it
yes it is it is a crowd developed by a
number of different engineers
three thousand different people in the
community like input from different
people
and it is oh i don't understand why
y'all think that all this
sounds funny i apologize
get my joint over again move on look
look rest in peace i'm sorry guys
it was actually um eurogamer talked
about it thank you very much
thank you special i respect that look
rest in peace 2080 ti
it was it was nice it was a good run i
was moving and shaking
but these dudes undercut you and i'm
gonna be eating off those uh
sales right now with the teddy tiger way
to go look i gotta defend like addicts i
gotta defend consolation just a little
bit
we gotta stop acting like you're just
gonna have a card
and you're gonna put a plug in and
you're gonna put it into your monitor
and you're gonna be doing this
performance there's a lot of factors
here
we gotta be real oh it's the cost of the
cars right
some people do not have the motherboards
to support this stuff on the man
right some people do not have the
motherboards to support this some people
do not have the the power supply
wattage to support this you know and
then also i believe a pcie
four you know if you want to maximize it
to the fullest you know i mean so for
some people who are in position right
they're just gonna buy it they'll be
fine but the majority they're gonna have
to either upgrade their systems or buy
new systems and that's not gonna be at
the 500
price point so we gotta you know get
that out the way but the value
proposition
is definitely good i want to shout them
out on that at the end of the day
you get absolute value the 30 70 you
know slightly outperform the 2080 ti is
a big deal
for that price is a big deal and i do
agree with attic i thought the timing of
the card announcements
was interesting you know october
whatever right before that november
thing and i feel they want i agree i
think that they want to keep
those so this is mom i think they want
to keep people in the people that have
switched
because i think their gaming revenue is
going up and i think the people that
have switched
they want to keep them in that ecosystem
because let's be real prior to this
announcement
when the series x and the playstation 5
we heard that performance of 2080 ti
type performance and block
and ssds let's be real pc community was
was the back was against the wall a
little bit you know i'm saying because
they were
consoles were coming in hot you don't
see it as far as matching
you know i'm saying that level of
fidelity so this is pretty cool again
like king said we got she a big name for
that big
show up i cannot wait to see everybody
backpedaling and sliding under the back
of the door like no
you know what i had said to your defense
king
we still got to see official benchmarks
like
because a lot of the stuff we're seeing
is in control with certain game and this
that
like i want to see side by side and then
they really you know
when big navies show up it's not it's no
fun in this big mac
packet yeah the slow mo yeah he said
that the uh yeah the cpu yeah some
people ain't got the cpus you know i'm
saying they've run out of i5s too
so that's a good but if you have i7 yes
i agree 8700 you're going to be good
um yo stop get the super chat yeah move
on we got sweetie smith oh what the [ __ ]
is that lord [ __ ] it sounds very tc
ellis
look um you know sweaty sweat as as an
ambassador of tcl
i i i don't approve of that
then we got one away with the two
dollars super chat styles monitor the
deep blacks will be great
that's what we're doing kingdom though
and this is true
saab i saw way too many horror stories
on e to pre-order that monitor it looks
like a dream come true
spec wise though and that's the thing
the specs
are for a monitor because you know you
don't really see crazy specs on a 4k
monitor
it's 800 that's what picks a big juicer
a tv yep
all right let's get that rough ride
sweetie smith with the final
super chat potluck monitors
everybody's different there we go
jonathan b with the five dollar super
chat i heard the new tcl's coming out
actually have hdmi
yo that's stupid they're stupid look
last what i'll say is this oh the real
quick
i don't know went away i don't really
want to say this because i don't
it sounds like something by the lordish
lol i don't know what i'm not saying
that word
[Laughter]
there we are stitch with the two dollar
super chat isn't spectrum the tcl's of
monitor
oh oh man and then we have
30 is greater than 12 teraflops wow
disrespectful record yeah we're done all
right cool last point is look the
billion dollar question
i gotta ask this do you think because of
that because of their omnividia joint
dropping away
like did that put pressure on what put
it this way
do you think they had eddie saw you get
anything to do with
this price chicken with maybe that
microsoft and so they knew what the
video might be doing maybe that
part of the stay-down game but it has
nothing to do with it
i don't think that's going to do
anything like they really are different
lanes like
unless you're somebody who also has a a
pc that
you would only have to replace the gpu
in fact
or you were just really ready like me to
finally buy another tower
on time like otherwise it's not a
conversation for you it's not a real
this doesn't affect anybody in console
because the people that are going to go
out and buy this day one
they decided that long before these
specs even came out
like we're talking about the cat daddies
the you guys the
you know um you know
when it comes to these type of movements
they're going to buy this they can
literally come out and they could say
that the next series x oh we messed up
it's 30 teraflops the the the pcp will
be like
that's cute i'm still buying a pc i'm
still going pc like they don't care they
they want the freedom
of the platform and that's what they
care about you know people want the
freedom of
an open platform on pc but only get on
steam but that's that's besides the
points
anyway so we we're gonna get that last
night also the living flame with the two
dollars super chat nvidia basically just
put their meat on the table
oh they did they did it the problem is
they didn't put it on the table the
constants are out there
yo you stupid yeah
super mario 3d author the 35th
anniversary of super mario brothers
and nintendo look at grandpa grandpa
may not know a lot of things right
grandpa is not good
at at working with the internet it's not
good about that grandpa doesn't
understand
i don't think grandpa knows that the
internet's even exists yeah i really
really don't think
grandpa doesn't really get bluetooth you
know like grandpa's not really great
with the
with the wii feed they got it
but what grandpa knows how to do is to
make money hand
over fist
taking their base and dragging their
face through the mud
[Music]
smiles and enjoys it
so for me what they did with this then
all these announcements right which i
was a nintendo fan i enjoyed
they basically took a page out of walt
disney's handbook
and basically created the nintendo vault
the nintendo wall get it before it's
gone forever
okay so let's clarify real quick let's
frame it so nintendo is releasing
a limited time package super mario 3d
all-stars arrives on september 18th for
60 dollars but it'll only be available
until approximately
march 31st 2021 stick them up
presumably the game will be released in
both physical and digital editions but
it seems they
don't intend on keeping the digital
version available
indefinitely so the the rumor like you
say solve is that they
they're reserving the right to make more
money on these games
get it before it's gone because at some
point in the near future we're going to
separate them out and sell them to you
individually
thank you that's what we're going to do
um anybody who
who who's my age knows that
it you watch commercials back in the day
where they'll be like
get bambi now before it's gone forever
better
bambi again for the tenth time because
this time it's gone forever
and you're gonna put it back in the vote
and then the thing is they literally use
that verbiage they said it'd be gone
forever
the only time uh any disney property's
ever been gone forever is like song of
the south
and i think we all agree the song of
this house needs to be in the bushes
forever like
beyond that it's it's just marketing
right to get people to buy a repackage
of
of these things and look i'm gonna be
the first one to say i frauded and went
out and purchased
two copies shout out to them shout out
to betty today
shout out shut up yeah i got i i got
three oh
my god so we are capitulating we are
back
it's like i said when you know lord ryan
mccaffrey is on here
i can criticize and be respectful
wow i'm gonna criticize myself
y'all thought it was something new you
thought oh okay they're gonna put three
mario games in one package and they
ain't gonna fall they ain't gonna stick
you up in some form or fashion
well today nintendo is doing something
great for the community they always do
something great
and just turn around and say ah
right in the back so as you're reaching
for it they was poking you right in the
back they told you
get it now or forever hold your peace
and then next year soon is it out as
soon as they
they cut production soon they they cut
the the internet on it and like no you
cannot buy it no more here
or as soon as they stop production you
can't get it no more hand dudes on ebay
go on buck bananas
put a virtual console out with all those
games individually
this is the thing right like we talk
about
all these like anti-consumer practices
activision and we
they are they are none worse they are
the epitome and we smile and take it
yeah
because it's good old nintendo it's
gonna be live
i gotta buy this game
i love every last one of
you know you know i say it all the time
sort of uh lord bg
it's easy to boycott something you don't
care about i know facts
for some people don't like mario they do
the same stuff they doing now to zelda
they gonna be writing factual you're
gonna like the boys
and i'm buying both because it's just
like at the end of the day
i don't agree with this because i think
this is gonna get worse
because in three years when nintendo's
doing this to everything
and you know you could say you could
look back on iop on episode
which one we are what's up before 174 be
like
i didn't contribute to this
it's a test run this is a test run to
see if you fool's
gonna fall for this joint again and all
of us goofies is gonna be like he's
gonna nintendo here's the money
and then they're gonna say yo you want
that three zelda pack
please they got the packs
in three weeks majora's mask
with swords oh twilight princess silva
in a four pack
and people are gonna be like oh oh see
so how long do we have to get this
two more stick up get it now getting
high you know what i think they're gonna
do they're gonna start
re-releasing these old games because
they want like it's not
it's not enough to to short print
anymore like now
they don't want to just like have very
few copies out there now they just go
stop
making the comments they are the kings
of the artist
you know like the thing yeah you know
how like when something happens in
in destiny like okay you got a certain
amount of time to get it if i don't get
it this time it's hard to tell the next
time this event is going to be out so i
have to wait a whole year
they doing this oh man mario like if i
march they going to do it for six months
after that
yeah i gotta go down there right now
they got emboldened
by ea when ea told you you could do the
upgrade on madden
but in march you're done i don't know
what's happening in march yeah that's
what delivery yeah
but in march some something's going on
in march
hilarious if mark goes up and nothing
happens it'll be fun
that's what you did we got we got errata
misses the five dollar super chat the
big and found another way to fraud their
way into stealing money from their cult
that yes they did yes they did that's
the fact then we got smitty smith with
the two dollars sweet chat nintendo we
got an offer you can't refuse that
dizzy nintendo's the real members only
jacket wearing company
it's not anti-consumer it's more get in
line
before the club closes be obvious we did
that for you
they are they're like yo i'm gonna give
you a time limit to buy this we're gonna
put three of these games
and guess what we ain't doing nothing
too no no we'd even
we need a rematch it's straight port at
the laziest level
there's no wide screen support let me go
in man because this joint right here
like switch gang you know i've been
riding with this right here
man yo then on why is it limited
why is the digital limited what what's
happening with the digital that you
gotta remove it off the store
physical i get it limited run packaging
okay cool
why are you removing the digital joy
from the storefront fam
bandwidth to last for six months like
that's the
listen shout out to just going windows
central xbox 2. he got the tweet of the
year
he says microsoft will uprez
and upgrade your old games for free with
our backward compatibility tech shout
out to bill still in there he was part
of
nintendo we'll sell you your old games
back to you at full price
and by the way you have to buy them by
an arbitrary date because we want to
manufacture a psychological sense of
urgency
it's so true it is so true i just sit
there and i'm like yo
they get away with it what's funny is
activision vilified
ea vilified every company that does this
gets the smoke nintendo yo i put this in
a nintendo forum
why are you complaining you're not going
to buy it i'm like yo
i'll put a lawyer gamer to shout out to
undead he's got an amazing article on
this
you know it says like nintendo just
finds a way to be painfully nintendo
this is painfully nintendo bro
unbelievable and then the last point and
nobody i don't see talk about it is on
fam
what's up with um super mario all stars
too why is that not part of this
what's going on like why are we like
yeah like why are we not acting like
that
and apparently it's rumored of them
apparently yeah
apparently it's rumored that that was
supposed to be out uh that was
that was originally going to be part of
this package up until eight months ago
and then they cut it
it's like okay so this is gonna happen
like i'm a future
man it's my crystal ball they gonna drop
this
and then drop the package in march and
then they're gonna drop that game for
forty dollars
in march shout out to anthony truman he
said the digital game will self-destruct
yo it's a fact this don't listen man oh
good
the pc super mario 64 fan remastered
blows it out the water yes
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna confirm or
deny that i have that on my desktop
um and then we have bill still he says
nintendo the first taste
is free yeah they like
they're the best hustlers the first
taste is free
faction the super chat we have the wise
old gamer with the five dollars which
had nintendo separating the tcl crowd
from the money
they don't have from day one that is
that is you know you know
it's hell it's find a way to purchase a
nintendo product
it's going to be like a week before they
take it off the marketplace
and this is going to quickly rise to be
the most soul
game they have no that's gonna blast mpd
out the water
that's all i got man they're gonna have
like a one-to-one ratio it's gonna have
like 60 million
yeah and we we didn't even talk about
the fact that they're releasing a
limited edition gaming watch
with the again separating people from
their money
they have they have a super mario battle
royale basically coming
out they got that crazy looking mario
cartoon that you have you you set up
cart you set up tracks in your house
like that um
we got a super chat nintendo hustle game
is strong yes sir
sir yes sir we have six slayer with the
ten dollar super chat nintendo has no
new games coming something has to be
happening in march
maybe the switch pro finally and all the
have better been held back for that
but you would have expected it to be
back compat i whatever the next switch
is
yes it's going to be back compatible
they're not going to make that mistake
again
we're creating an upgrade that only
played certain games
they did that with the new nintendo yes
in the switch family yes you you believe
that you believe that
you believe these dudes
listen nintendo's the only company i got
to say i got to see it first
i don't trust you yeah
i'm not saying that they're going to be
back i don't say anything they might be
like yo
this is the whole solely separate thing
y'all like that switch yeah do that but
we got this new thing over here
with a double face that don't trust them
dude
and i'm sure whatever it is it's going
to be super amazing
anyway new ipo po with the latest
announcements and controversy
uh super mario 3d collection being a
limited
release port do you think nintendo
fairly or
unfairly gets a pass on these practices
choices are hey you don't even have to
read everything everyone's gonna vote
yes
no this isn't anything new nintendo are
amazing at meeting the demands of their
fans
what was calvin writing that one yes
pure greed minimal effort and fake
urgency
well see i don't care because it's order
popping when they do the og
zelda versions of this
shout out to all those that's in the
room don't get wise
we got the wise old gamer with the 2000
chat say what you will but the nintendo
pimp hand is strong oh they they hit you
with
all the talcum powder all the time yes
white glove all that smack so look man
that is a question please rock the vote
when it goes up yo salute laura ryan
mccaffrey was up in the room
iconic moment for the lords a lot of fun
tremendous history please salute that
man like i say
doing a lot of things out there in the
gaming industry and it was a pleasure to
have him in the round we'll be trying to
do more stuff like this for you guys
it was really a lot of fun lord addict
where can the five people find you what
you got going on sir any more hot videos
you can find me on twitter lord addicts
iop you can find me at
youtube gaming addict i'll definitely be
making some videos this week
uh you can also find me over here
playing wasteland three
and i'm gonna play that outer worlds dlc
when it comes out yeah you know i'll
drop i don't know but uh
i definitely wanna you know uh say
thanks to you know lord ryan for coming
on it was yes it was a pleasure
to do uh you know some uh do content
with them
and definitely you know i i want to
thank all the people all the lords in
the realm you know
you guys came up that we had like 350 at
one point you know we had
262 definitely that like button if you
guys aren't here by now
and you know we'll see you next week yes
sir
lord solve we can find people finding
what you got going on sir
yeah first of all man big shout out to
ryan for coming on that was definitely a
bucket list moment to have ryan
mccaffrey on i.l.p
i i i never really listened to podcasts
before and then when when my work
schedule started getting bonkers like
cog told me like yo you need to listen
to podcasts and that was the very first
one i started listening to and then i've
been hooked ever since
and look what we're doing now so big
shout out to ryan for being so honest
too
yeah brutal honesty yeah this is giving
us a lot of bars
he's a genuinely nice person who
really understands the way things have
been
and and and honestly the only person who
when things happened made changes to try
to
address that and continues to do it
whereas other people like cox said kind
of
cool all the no mentions of of the
hashtag for how
exactly exactly so i i'm so appreciative
of ryan and what he does
um and then with me of course you can
find me at work under the end
because uh the school year is about to
start which means that saab will be
getting four hours of sleep per night
so i will be officially in the bushes
from this moment forward
for my kids my kids
smart on you smart on you no doubt lord
king
bringing the heat as always in the realm
where can i find people finding
tremendous kos
up right now first and foremost i would
like to
salute uh lord ryan um
this today you know where it hit me
when he said terrible graphics yeah yeah
yeah it was all it was on
when he when it's oh my god
because we look at these individuals
that we see
on shows or on tv or whatever or we read
you know their articles and magazines
and we put them on a pedestal and we put
them out of reach
we we make them
you know gods basically absolutely and
to talk to him and hear his experiences
and his experiences
his mirroring minds and he was an out of
the box dude
yeah he wasn't the same path guy
and do you know how alone i was with
this turbo graphics man
like dude was like why did you buy that
i mean [ __ ] and i appreciated it we just
didn't get it
fantastic yeah we love that system we'll
play yours
and you know he him and his boy had it
and
you know you talk about ease you know
it's these things
it humbles you to know
and i hope when you watch this show back
you learn one very particular thing
because cog said that we say it all the
time
we are all gamers facts it is
one thing that binds us to have us sit
here
that we talk about things we are gamers
so i just want to say thank you again
it's it's a it's a magical moment this
you know
i have tons of magical moments with a
lot of our guests
but this one very particularly
hit because he was out of the box like i
was and in in
and i know how he felt period bill
stillwell agrees with you he said
actually show one of your best i'd say
top three for sure
seriously though ryan is one of the good
guys great fit with you all because
you're all great people too
salute salute thank you definitely
bucket list i'm sorry i let you finish k
well no no just you know get on to that
kos
if you haven't seen it really check it
out because it's uh
it's a slice of hurt yeah right it's a
it's a real slice of hurt
i had to do that video three times i
cried twice
doing it it's a slice of hurt go check
it out
um add me on
uh playstation network at a xbox 360
level one
you know when i had to register for my
playstation 5 it
didn't want to take my id it was like no
i mean you over here with these eggs
i do want to point something out real
quick for a close super chat i want to
give
a special shout out to bill stilwell
this dude he's been here since day one
and he's
in our chat right now you know he was
dead when
um bro like turn himself
like he had literally yeah no business
being on this show oh i've told him his
face
and you know always tremendous respect
for the people who believe in the vision
as a couple and he's definitely
one of them so salute to him on that man
much love i want to get emery because
he's been waiting
on the chat say hello to pc emulator for
mario games for me
murray i will not confirm or deny that i
actually have that on my desktop
[Laughter]
but look man tremendous day in the room
salute to everybody in the chat man wow
ryan mccaffrey definitely a buckles
moment please watch me play if you
missed it
he dropped tremendous tremendous jewels
a lot of stuff to learn fine we're very
proud to have hopefully we'll do more
stuff like that in the future you
already know last word is up there
catch that also scribe of the month
lawsongaming.net
jared you're the first winner of this
and i'm saying congratulations what
we're doing open critic all the
greatness
please hit that lords of gaming.net man
opinion pieces
articles reviews check us out man it
really
really means a lot to us to see this our
little fledgling thing grow into
something special and great
people all backgrounds cro all worlds
croatia women women female every we got
it all man we need a melted pot and
louisiana down there so i'm super proud
of that
and then of course you already know i'm
gonna hit you with the promo with king
we got that serious x and soon
another promo that someone's supposed to
be doing
then we have to get done
but look everybody enjoy your sunday
really
special episode y'all really was
christmas yeah christmas
chris is up in there all day he was
chilling having a good old time he's
having a good hotel
everybody this was less on the console
stuff so like
he just sat back and enjoyed the show
enjoyed the show yeah exactly and i know
that's true
next week when we have some more news
i'm sure he's gonna be straight
12 is still better than eight
shout out to jay barry i see you pull up
in there yo again we all gamers man
that's the unifying thing right there
everybody enjoy your sunday we out of
here catch this promo
until next week peace hi
i'm lord king david of iron lords
podcast and
we're bringing to you an exciting new
giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able to be
part of that giveaway there's two ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
hit that joy button you hit that join
button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man